đang bận à
thậm chí là về quê rồi
nhở Chắc là hôm hôm nay buổi livestream
cuối năm thôi còn buổi sau
thì buổi sau hôm nay cũng không nhớ lịch
âm nàm lịch
âm hôm nay Lịch âm là hình như là cũng
hai mấy rồi 27 rồi 16
là sao
nhỉ em mà live xuân khai xuân code Á
kiểu livestream các thứ á
sau ờ ừ chắc là sau
hôm thứ năm này cho đến
A ngày
khái Xuân kiểu livestream thì chắc là
phải tận thứ ba Rồi sau nữa
à quên đấy ghim lại cái này
nữa Hôm nay Như tiêu đề các bạn thấy là
sẽ là một buổi tâm sự cuối năm các bạn
có những câu hỏi gì hoặc là Ừ tôi cứ
ngồi tâm sự một loạt đã xong rồi các bạn
thắc mắc gì thì các bạn có thể Cứ C chia
sẻ nhá Đợi tôi tí để tôi chỉnh lại cái
này nó đã bị mất cân bằng trông nó hơi
khó
sẻ nên chắc hôm nay nếu mà giả sử không
ai không ai kể tâm sự gì cả thì tôi sẽ
là người tâm sự ở chủ yếu
nhiên khi copy nó chèn thêm cả cái đấy
thì đầu tiên đầu tiên là
ờ nên chia sẻ cứ từ đầu đi nha không về
sau quên xứ những
cái càng cái về cuối này càng mấy cái
Gần đây tôi ghi lại ví dụ đển x hôm nay
ghi lại một vài cái này tôi nghĩ tôi nên
chia sẻ cái này mấy cái từ rất là lâu
rồi tôi đã kiểu ghi chú lại rất là lâu
rồi
Ừ tiên là không biết các bạn chắc chắn
là tôi nghĩ là các bạn từng nghe đ ha
cathon một lần Thậm chí nhiều lần thậm
chí là từng tham gia
Ờ tôi hồi trước tôi từng nghe nó
và tôi khá khá là tôi cảm thấy là khá là
ở đây ch là một trong những nối tiếc đó
là tôi không tham gia mấy cái h thon nà
cả bởi vì bởi vì tôi lúc nào tôi cũng
tưởng cái thời đấy là tôi
phải 1 hay hai năm đổ lại đây thì tôi
mới biết là hack caton nó không phải là
về mỗi hack mà nó về rất nhiều
cái nghĩa là ví dụ Giả sử ha thon lập
trình này hay các thứ các thứ rất nhiều
cái luôn ý và mình chỉn giả mình sẽ ghép
vào các đội để m mình ngồi kiểu ngồi làm
với nhau kiểu mấy ngày liền à xống từ
mấy ngày hơi quá Chắc chỉ một hai kiểu
trong vòng 36 Giờ thường là thế để kiểu
ở đấy C cầy để mà làm ra một cái sản
phẩm nào đó một cách tương đối xong rồi
mình sẽ thử thuy trình trịch bày ý tưởng
mọi thứ để thi thở thi đấu với nhau
Ờ thì tôi cảm thấy đấy là cái rất là hay
nghe về rất là hay nhưng mà cái thời
trước của tôi khi mà nghe hackathon tôi
lúc nào tôi cũng nghĩ nó là hack nên
thành ra tôi không tham gia cái nào cả
Còn bây giờ khi mà có hack Khi mà biết
rồi ấ thực ra mình có kinh nghiệm đấy
nhưng mà khá là ít hackathon về p phải
Tôi cảm thấy thế toàn thấy về bây giờ
chắc là nó nó sẽ mang thiên hướng ể công
nghệ hiện đại hơn tí giống như là
blockchain ai hoặc là vài ngôn ngữ
khác vài ngôn ngữ kiểu mới mới để thu
hút mọi người nên là nó không còn công
nghệ kiểu dạng là gi không kiểu ngồi làm
web nữa nên là tôi cảm thấy hơi tiếc thế
thậ ra tôi là một
người tôi tự đánh giá tôi không phải là
một người làm được mà là một người có
rất nhiều ý tưởng tôi có rất nhiều ý
tưởng ý nên là thành ra là kiểu Nếu mà
đi mấy cái kiểu như này tôi nghĩ là tôi
sẽ hoàn toàn thỏa sức ý tưởng của tôi có
thể nó khả thi có thể không nhưng mà tôi
cảm thấy là tôi có ngay từ hồi bé tôi đã
có rất nhiều ý tưởng để mà kiểu Hồi
trước kiểu cũng muốn cái bệ Danh Tôi Là
khái niệm bác học điên mà tức C chỉ cứ
nghĩ các thứ muốn làm phát minh hay muốn
làm ra một cái rất nhiều sản phẩm Một là
để hỗ trợ cuộc sống con người mình Bây
giờ hai là chỉ đơn giản là ừ
ở đại khái nó sẽ có mục đích gì đó để mà
hỗ trợ cuộc sống
mình tiếp theo cái link scam này
Ờ hôm đấy là có một bạn sinh viên gửi
tôi cái link đấy link đấy
là bây giờ để mà lục lại cái discord thì
chắc
là để để để xem tôi có lục lại được quả
discord này không nhá để link link đấy
tôi thấy là trông nó trông uy tín vãi
trưởng thực ra nó link scam mà cái quan
trọng đầu tiên thì phải giải thích các
bạn link scam là gì đúng không Nó chính
xác là gọi chung là scam tức cả lửa đảo
Nhưng mà thực ra là Trang đấy nó sẽ link
gọi là link fishing Cách Tấn Công là
fishing tức là
fit
là bình thường fit là con cá Fishing là
kiểu cấu cá nhưng mà fishing viết theo
kiểu khác thì nó sẽ là kiểu là câu người
ch câu cá nữa các bạn biết K đấy nh
ha bình thường là fishing như này đúng
không như đây sẽ là
fishing như này thì
phải
Đấy tức là
đây là là Hacker sẽ kiểu làm giảm cái
trang web kiểu trông như thật luôn để mà
các bạn vào đấy các bạn điền thông tin
các thứ các thứ hóa ra nó chẳng lừa đảo
Đợi tí tôi tìm lại cái link thôi nhưng
mà tôi không biết là tôi đăng lại link
cho mấy ông thì tôi cũng có bị bay màu
không kiểu link đấy link hack mà Ờ à
Không Phả đây là link lừa
xem lần cuối Tôi cập nhật Cái này là từ
bao giờ thì tôi
sẽ sẽ nhớ được
rất nhiều rồi
ạ công ty tôi đang làm Hiện tại thì tôi
chỉ đang làm ở một công công ty và công
ty đấy công ty product nó là về trang
thương mạ điện
à đây đầu tiên là có một bạn bị hack
nick discord sau bạn đi Spam tin nhắn
một loạt sau đó thì nó ở trên cái trang
là steam community.com đây chà
này không biết chia sẻ livestream cái
này không Cũng có bị bay không đấy nhìn
trông uy tín mà kiểu các thứ thứ xong
rồi tên miền thì cũng giống như là kiểu
dành cho cộng đồng của steam ấy cho dù
rõ ràng là chuẩn nó sẽ đây nó sẽ phải
là cái tên miền này nhưng mà không Nó
lấy được cái tên miền này Đấy home quay
lại hết about nhảy về cái cái này thì em
chỉ có mỗi trang này nó trang lừa đảo
Thôi đây toàn bộ cái của community này
là lừa đảo này đấy làm rất thật đúng
không ạ đều còn toàn bộ Cái này thì nhảy
sang một cái của Steel power này thì cái
này mới là Trang
thật chỉ bấm vàoo đây nó lại nhì ste
power Nói chung là mọi thứ đều chông vẻ
thật cho đến một vài nút ví dụ nút login
này Đấy Uầy nó điền sẵm thông tin mình
luôn à đ thế hay là Trang này Trang thật
nhỉ cảm thấy Trang này chang lừa hơn
vở có bạn à không không không Hình như
là Trang này Trang thật quên quên mất
quên mất trang này Trang thật nhưng mà
có một cách của ông hacker bấm vàoo
À đây nế Thế chắc là tôi sẽ phải chiếu
lên màn hình mẹ ông xem
rồi trai này vẫn là trang thật quên mất
đ đợ tí
thứ thứ trông có vẻ là uy tín Nhưng mà
bản chất đường dẫn nó sẽ là cái này
này nó là link đến cái trang khách khác
này thấy không link đến trang khác này
có bạn nào mà vô tình kiểu bấm vào bay
đấy Kiểu thể khá à đương nhiên là vào
vào đấy một cái gì đó khác không biết
được tôi chưa dám bấm tôi cũng chưa trên
máy này không cài máy ảo để tôi bấm thử
đấy quên mất steam steamcommunity.com
thì nó vẫn vẫn là Trang đúng nhưng mà ý
tôi là cái này này nó lừa Thực ra bản
chất nó đường dẫn này cơ đấy nghĩa là
anh em mình kiểu nhìn qua mình chự quan
mình nghĩ là kểu đây đây là link thật
không Thực ra Nó là một cái link
khác Ừ chứ không phải là cái
steamcommunity.com kia là lờ đảo quên
quên tự nhiên thấy là cái tài khoản mình
được lưu trên đấy rồi là mình nghi ngờ
ngay đấy Trang thật thì mình mới lưu chứ
Đấy thì mấy ông nói chung là
tôi tôi luôn nghĩ là kiểu dạng
là mình mang mình vẫn mang tiếng mình ở
dân it team mà Thế nên là thế nên là nó
vẫn có cái gì đó nó hơi bị áp lực vô
hình à Hay gì gì đó nghĩa chỉ là thứ
nhất là mình hạn chế có thể bị hack
khủng các thứ thứ mình Mình biết cài Win
một tí thì tốt cho dù rõ rng là Trên lớp
có thể là các bạn không hề được dạy mấy
cái điều đấy nhưng mà nói chung là các
bạn cũng sẽ phải làm quen việc là sẽ có
người hỏi các bạn thứ nhất là cái Win
này Thứ hai là hỏi tư vấn về mua máy
tính này đấy Ờ
cái đấy thì tôi nghĩ là các bạn cũng nên
biết một tí cơ bản giống như kiểu Ờ ram
m nhất biết ram này hay chip này để làm
gì Vân vân nên mua như nào thì không bị
à hoặc là ý ra là nên mua ở đâu chẳng
hạn thế Như Không Thể Nói là kiểu trên
trường em không dạy mấy cái này nên em
không biết và em chỉ biết mỗi công việc
của em thôi thì nó nó nó cứ kiểu đầu
tiên thì nh người hỏi các bạn sẽ thấy là
Ừ trong mắt tao thì mày bị vừa bị giảm ở
cấp độ kiểu thấy không còn uy tín nữa
nếu mà tưởng n Nghe Dân I ngầu thì giờ
mày sẽ bị giảm đi cái độ ngầu đấy đấy
Cái thứ nhất thứ hai đó là
Ừ thứ hai đó là gì nhỉ
ờ thì mấy cái đấy Tôi nghĩ là nó kiến
thức không có gì kiểu ghê gớm cả chẳng
qua là người thường người ta cứ bị ngại
để mà tìm hiểu tức ra họ vẫn tìm hiểu
được mà ai tìm hiểu cũng được Chẳng cần
nói Z cà Win thì cũng chỉ next next
finish Bây giờ cà này càng đơn giản rồi
X còn mấy cái cấu hình máy tính thì chắc
là nó biết mình bước cơ B cùm lắm mà khi
người ta hỏi các bạn là các bạn biết
hack hủng gì không Các bạn cứ trả lời
không thế thôi giống như tôi
thì tôi nghĩa là mấy cái Ừ cái đấy không
phải là kiến thức cơ bản mà mình phải
biết mà mình nên biết để mình hỗ trợ cho
mọi người đấy ít nhất là không để bị
hack hủng không để các thứ thứ Bởi vì
bởi vì nếu Chính vì mấy ông nghe ngầu
trong mắt người khác bởi vì mấy ông là m
j xong rồi mấy ông Chính mấy ông bị hack
x mấy ông Gửi link cho người ta ví dụ
trong trường hợp này tôi được gửi link
như tôi biết để tự nhiên bấm vào nó
đường link lão hoắc kia nhưng là người
khác thì thứ nhất là họ không biết họ
còn nghĩ ơ ông ở Dân IT thì chắc ông bị
hack đâu Đây là link thật đấy họ bấm vào
đúng không Thì bản thân là ông vô hình
có thể đấy có thể kể hỗ trợ được cho
hacker khác hack người khác nữa đúng
không dựa trên độ uy tín của chính mình
đúng không ạ nên một là ông không khoe
Ông là dân dân IT ông mới nói là em đ
kiểu đi chạy việc vặt hai là khi mà ông
đã nói Ông là dân IT rồi thì chắc chắn
là hình chung rất nhiều người rất nhiều
người sẽ nghĩ mình kiểu gì nhở
Ờ vua của mọi nghề à hay các gì gì đó
đại khái
kiểu nó sẽ bị áp lực khá nhiều nên là
nhưng mà thứ nhất là họ nghĩ mình ngầu
Đã thế nên là thế nên là kiểu mình làm
được khả năng trong khả năng mình thì
mình cứ nói À đúng rồi C bảo sửa chữa
sửa chữa thì nói mấy cái kiểu đùa thôi
giống như là kiểu Hồi trước ấ hồi trước
trước có nhưng tôi vẫn kể tôi từng kể
mấy ông chưa nhỉ Tôi từng có một người
từng từng hỏi tôi là có sửa cho họ được
cái điều hòa hay không th Tôi bảo là
ông tìm dây cắm mạng cắm mạng vào cái
điều hòa tôi kiểu sửa online cho đấy đến
bây giờ họ vẫn chưa trả lời Chắc họ vẫn
đang đi tìm đấy Kiểu
thế Nói chung
đánh đố mình mình kiểu đánh đố lại họ
bằng một cái gì
đó kiểu mày làm được cái này tao mới làm
được tiếp không là sao ta sửa được Đấy
Thế là được đúng
À nói thế nhưng mà kiểu bố mẹ mà nhờ
xong rồi Cái thứ thứ thì mình chắc mình
vẫn hỗ trợ được mà hỗ trợ bằng cách gọi
thợ
ờ thật sự là tôi không giỏi làm việc nhà
làm n tôi thì có quan điểm là những cái
thứ mình giỏi thì mình cứ cố phát huy có
những thứ mình không giỏi thì mình kiếm
người giỏi làm hộ mình cái điều đấy thế
nên là kiểu ví dụ Giả sử là bây giờ ông
giả sử Giả sử là kiểu ông dù cứ làm nào
giùng tôi đi lời làm việc nhà vãi chưa
Không kiểu không biết làm luôn ý kiểu
không biết làm thì làm Nó sẽ bị kiểu
đương nhiên là làm vẫn tốt không phải
nói là thấy lười không làm gì cả làm mọi
thứ vẫn tốt nhưng ta nói có Nhữ nh cái
việc mà mình vấy ví dụ sửa chữa mấy cái
gì điện đóm chẳng hạn đấy nó vừa nguy
hiểm nếu mà đặc biệt là mình không biết
làm thì đấy do mà kiểu mấy ông Ờ kiếm
được gọi là kiếm được nhiều tiền rồi các
thứ các thứ thì mấy ông đi thuê mấy ông
kiểu các thứ th nhờ người khác hỗ trợ
cho đương nhiên nó sẽ có nhược điểm là
nó không tiện lợi cho lắm bởi vì là phải
đợi người ta đúng không ạ đợi người ta
đến hỗ trợ có thử
Ờ gọi trong lúc mà người ta đang làm
việc của người ta thì mình làm việc tốt
của mình Mình kiếm được để bù lại còn
hơn là bây giờ ông
à tôi vẫn không Tôi đang nói trên góp
nhìn của tôi vì tôi bản chất là tôi cũng
chưa được ai dạy cả các thứ còn nếu mà
ông biết rồi thì tôi nghĩ là ông vẫn nên
chủ động
làm
anh có làm việc với view chưa Công ty
vẫn
là n gọi là n đúng không n
CS nó Framework của view đấy công ty anh
đang dùng Thế chứ giờ công ty mà vẫn
dùng J thì đúng là công ty một
là
một là kiểu dạng thực ra là nó Đa số mà
bây gi tôi nhưng mà nó vẫn khá là tồi
thấy đa số ở đây Bởi Vì Đa số ở đây là
gọi là công ty cũng dùng những công nghệ
rất cũ rồi và ngại kiểu đập đi làm lại
vân vân vân mà thấy khá
tệ nếu mà mấy Em làm công ty đấy thì
đúng là tôi không phải nói hơi tí cứ
khuyên mấy ông nghỉ việc
được Nhưng mà thực sự thực sự là các bạn
nên nên kiểu cũng cân nhắc là chỉ là học
được cái gì ở đấy học xong rồi Ừ kiểu
truyển
Anh ơi em buộc phải học re trong 1 tháng
để làm đ án muôn học thì cái này có khả
thí không Nếu mà em biết về ngôn ngữ lập
trình nào đó rồi thì học ngôn ngữ lập
trình khác rất là nhanh đặc biệt là đặc
biệt là nếu em biết ra scrip rồi thì học
react sang học react react Hình như là
bản chất nó ra scp nhỉ Thôi Chưa tôi còn
đấy tôi còn chưa Kiểu nhìn xem à react
kiểu dạng nó là như nào
cơ Đúng rồi react là ra Script mà Ừ nó
giống tôi nhớ nó đ là giống view mà ừ
thế chắc là em sẽ học khá nhanh thôi
trong một tháng thoải mái nếu mà tầm cỡ
của anh anh kiểu Lead Hồi trước của tôi
là hai ngày ngồi đọc tài liệu để xem cú
pháp mà khác gì nhau x nhảy vào làm luôn
Hồi trước đấy anh mới chỉ làm mỗi angula
Hồi đấy Con chưa có view à đâu nhầm gọi
lại nhỉ Hồi đấy Anh học hai ngày angula
rồi anh nhảy vào làm luôn cho dù Hồi đấy
chưa biết view chưa có view luôn Chưa có
view chưa có react Hồi đấy anh em biết
về mỗi ra scrip với Z thôi
đấy còn bây giờ thì mình Trình độ không
phải thế thì mình cứ gấp
kiểu gấp 15 lần lên 30 ngày thoải mái
mà
Ờ học mình larel được thôi được không
anh
Ờ nếu mà em xác định chỉ biết về Bá en
ấy thì mà em phải phải tự tin cái khoản
kiến thức back của em rất khủng n ná
giống như kiểu bây giờ tôi cũng hơi tự
tin khoản back end của tôi ở trên công
ty nên là thành ra tôi làm gần như là
chủ yếu bend còn fan là người khác sẽ hỗ
trợ cho tôi đương nhiên tôi hoàn toàn có
thể làm phươ stack nhưng mà Kiểu cái
thời gian làm finan tôi thì đúng là tôi
tôi vẫn làm được ja Script các thứ ổn
nhá Nhưng thứ nhất là về khoản giao diện
thì mình làm hơi yếu này CS hơi yếu này
thứ hai đó là là có nhiều chỗ mình cứ
kiểu mình cứ cấn cấn bởi vì cái cách xử
lý của JavaScript nó khác với pp chắc là
chắc là tôi gần đây tôi cũng phải tôi
bảo đấy tôi cũng phải học với bổ sung
làm quen dần với cái vụ đấy là xử quen
với việc xử lý đồng gọi là tuần tự với
bất với bất tuần tự đấy C thứ thứ mình
sẽ phải học kiểu cách khác biệt của các
ngôn ngữ khác nhau các thứ tôi vẫn làm
ra scp back end à fullstack Ở công ty
vẫn ổn
nhá Ừ đúng rồi bất đồng bộ không nhưng
mà tôi đang nói tuần tự à Không phải
Đúng rồi tu Tôi đang nói chung nữa tuần
tự bất tuần tự của Java phải Java bất
tuần tự đúng không À đây nó là xử lý đây
bất đồng bộ hay tuần tự hay cái gì đó
đấy xử lý songong song các thứ thứ nữa
của Java nữa đấy Nói chung là vài ngôn
ngữ nó sẽ có nhiều kiểu cái xử lý kiểu
cái luồng xử lý nó khác nhau nên là mình
sẽ phải làm quen tất cả để mà để mà về
để mình không biến cái ngôn ngữ Lập
trình là một cái giào cản của mình nữa
nghĩa là mình chỉ dùng được một hai hai
ngôn ngữ lập trình
không câu câu mà tôi vẫn thích đó là
kiểu ngôn ngữ lập trình bản chất nó chỉ
là công cụ thôi Em chỉ là đấy giống như
tôi vừa nói đó là là ở công ty trước của
tôi đó là hồi đấy chỉ làm mỗi pp thuần
kiểu larel thôi cả fun cả bác xong rồi
về sau thấy xử lý bị nặng quá á thì mới
bắt bắt đầu là dùng Java với
dnet để mà kiểu xử lý những dữ liệu lớn
Sau đó thì trả về cho trả về cho pp để
pp trả về cho kiểu fanel Hồi đấy Làm
kiểu kiểu thế nghĩa là sau đó thì fanel
fanel bằng pp nó vẫn nặng nên là Bọ Tôi
dùng fw JavaScript nữa là angula để mà
kiểu in ra cho nó nhanh đấy n ông chỉ
Bọn tôi hồi đấy không quan tâm là mình
đang thạo ngôn ngữ gì mấy anh kia hoàn
toàn có tư duy để nhảy sang bất kỳ ngôn
ngữ nào để mấy anh ấy làm mấy anh đấy
Tôi vẫn nhớ là công ty đấy công ty đầu
tiên tôi thực tập à anh đấy tất cả anh
ấy có ba anh à đâu diện có bốn anh đều
học Bách Khoa nhưng mà một anh là CEO là
học về kinh tế còn ba anh còn lại thì
đều học về kiểu công nghệ thông tin xong
rồi tất cả mấy anh đấy đều có có 10 năm
kinh nghiệm để mà thành lập ra cái công
ty đấy thế nên là hồi đấy
Kiểu hồi đấy kiểu dạng là toàn thấy m
rất là ngầu và rất là xịn mỗi tội là tôi
làm ở đấy cũng đấy tôi nhớ Tôi có kể đó
là tôi làm đấy nửa năm rồi Tôi cũng phải
nghỉ vì anh sếp co kia thích bóc lộ xước
l động quá anh ấy bảo là kiểu khi nào mà
em Trình độ em bằng kiểu các bạn các bạn
nhân viên khác thì em sẽ kiểu được lương
chính thức đấy các bạn nhân viên khác
thì toàn 10 năm kinh
database Ai là người làm vẽ thực ra thì
thường thì sẽ là một là da là data
database architect Nhưng mà thường là
tôi thấy rất ít cái dự án tôi tính là
tôi chưa gặp một da thực sự bao giờ C
lắm là data analy thì tôi thấy nhiều
phải có yêu cầu rất nhiều kinh nghiệm
chứ ít được kiểu dạng đi thực tập cái
cái cái đấy á nên thường là leader là
người có tầm nhìn à để mà kiểu ngồi
thiết kế Build và có một tí kinh nghiệm
rồi nhưng mà không phải leader nào cũng
chuẩn hôm trước ngay vừa hôm trước luôn
Tôi vừa đi chữa
à Tôi vừa đi cà phê và chữa cho một bạn
bạn ấy cũng chỉ học khóa SQL của tôi
thôi Tôi không tự tin là kiểu dạng là
SQL mình kiểu quá xịn rồi bởi vì bản
chất là tôi vẫn còn phải đăng ký à Tôi
đây cho mấy ông xem luôn là trong năm n
à không phải trong năm này mà chính xác
là trong
lấy vợ đấy tôi nói luôn cái mục đích à
Cái định hướng của tôi các thứ trong ha
năm tới đó là luyện âm này học luyện âm
để mà học nói chuyện kiểu kiểu dạng à
luyện luyện thanh của để mà nói chuyện
diễn giả của MC chuyên nghiệp ấy sau
tiếp học ở bên anh Huy Này anh Huy này ở
bên we commit à về tối ưu cơ sở liệu và
truy vấn các thứ đấy nghe nghe nói thế
Tôi chưa học nên và cũng chỉ xem qua vài
video trên YouTube anh đấy thì thầy có
vẻ rất là xịn chưa học được Nên khó đánh
giá cũng chưa gặp anh ấy ngoài đời bao
giờ tôi không quảng cáo gì đâu nhá Tôi
chia sẻ Thật là tôi sẽ học và mấy bên
này thật còn mấy ông mà đã từng đăng ký
đã từng học qua thì có thể đưa tôi lời
khuyên thì càng tốt tiếp theo là bên anh
sang anh sang này
bên người viết mã anh này
cũng bản chất thì anh ấy cũng chuyên về
bend đặc biệt chuyên hệ thống đó là bao
gồm cả cơ sở liệu đấy nhưng mà và cả
code
nữa anh ấy kiểu dạng tư duy về
repository tôi không nhớ cách phát âm nó
lắm đấy các thứ về TH thiết kế hệ thống
ở đây bao gồm cái thiết kế về code các
thứ các tầng các tầng layer để mà code
sao cho nó kiểu nó tách bạch Nó kiểu nó
gọi nh chẳng biết dùng từ nữa nhưng mà
dùng từ chuyên nghiệp thì không hẳn là
đúng lắm Bởi vì đấy là theo cái từ
chuyên nghiệp là theo quan điểm của mỗi
người để đánh giá bởi có nhiều người
thấy là kiểu code thế nó cũng bị phức
tạp lên cũng có tự nhiên là nhìn vào
code nó bị phức tạp hơn bình thường cũng
có đấy nhá gọi
là bình thường Bạn nhìn thấy code xử lý
ở hết một chỗ bây giờ bạn phải nhảy qua
bao nhiêu tầng các th thứ thì bạn hiểu
được luôn code nên là cũng bị choáng đấy
nhưng mà gọi là nó sẽ rất là xịn cho
những cái kiểu tầm cỡ là kiểu cao hơn
đúng không À kiểu dạng là kiểu dạng là
ông lên Ông viết code đấy xong người
khác mà một khi đã hiểu được cái đoạn
code đấy của ông để mà làm thì lại làm
rất rất là dễ và sửa rất là dễ
tôi vẫn muốn đi dậy nên chắc là tôi sẽ
thi cái chứng chỉ sư phạm vì tính ra là
tôi không qua một cái lớp sư phạm nào cả
cho dù tôi đã từng nghe từ nghe khá là
dùng từ nhiều không đúng tôi nghe lời
của vài người nói đó là cái này code để
lấy chứng chỉ thôi nó không học hành
được gì mấy nên chắc là tôi sẽ cân nhắc
tiếp theo là hai cái nữa hai cái nữa là
kiểu Cái này là định hướng sau sau sau
của tôi Thứ nhất là tôi cũng
muốn tôi muốn sang chung kiểu cảm thấy
là
à Hồi trước thì tôi từng rất là kiểu Hồi
bé hồi bé tôi cuồng nhất là
à Mỹ kiểu thiên nghe thiên đường các thứ
thứ đúng không gọi thiên đường để mà
mình tự do thoải mái và là phát triển
mọi thứ xứ sở tự do à xứ sở gì nhá Tôi
nhớ có một cái từ của nó rất là
hay Tôi tạm chưa nghĩ
ra thiên đường của Thiên Tài á hay cái
gì đấy ông nào nhớ thì nhắc tôi phát Ờ
đấy Thì đại khái Mỹ kiểu là giấc mơ Mỹ à
không sứ sở cờ hoa không phải nó có liên
quan đến kiểu dạng là kiểu để cho ông
phát triển được bản thân không ý kiểu à
tinh hoa hội tụ thì phải đấy th nhớ thế
hình như thế Có một từ khác nữa thì
phải kiểu chứ kiểu nơi đến Hồi đấy tôi
kiểu lên tưởng cứ đến đấy thì ông hoàn
toàn kiểu được trọng dụng cái nhân tài ấ
cái gọi là tài năng của mình ấy đấy Ờ
đấy hồi bé còn lớn lên một tí thì mình
thành một thằng bu nên thành ra là kiểu
xong rồi Kiểu nghe kiểu Truyền Hồng các
thứ thứ thì rất là thần tượng biết thần
tượng nước nào đấy ạ đó là Nhật đúng
không ạ xong rồi Gần đây tôi kiểu cũng
hơi bị sụp đổi hình tượng đấy Tí về
khoản kiểu còn người Nhật nói nghe nói
chung Nghe nói chung là cũng giả tạo các
thứ thứ n Tôi không thích lắm nữa vì
kiểu đấy bên đấy học học bơ kiểu kiểu
dạng là
ờ nhá kiểu bên đấy bị áp lực bản thân
quá kiểu cầy các thứ thứ chính bạn tôi
học it sang đấy lại đi làm đi làm Ả nói
nhá không phải mỗi đi học nhá B học Bách
Khoa khoa tiếng nhật xong rồi bạn sang
ng là xong rồi bạn làm 2 năm xong rồi
bạn về bỏn bỏ người luôn nghề vì cảm
thấy kiểu à sau hai nm đấy quá đủ quá áp
lực với bạn đấy rồi cho lương bạn ấy
cũng rất là cao ở bên đấy
Nhưng đương nhiên gần đây Bạn có quay
lại rồi quay lại làm rồi nên là tôi bắt
đầu khôi phục lại một phần niềm tin
nhưng mà khôi phục ở đây không phản khôi
phục hết bởi vì Ờ ông ấy bởi vì ông ấy
kiểu sau 2 năm đấy ông ông ấy về ông ấy
chán thôi đúng không Ông ấy bỏ bỏ luôn
ngành bỏ luôn nghề xong chuyển qua kinh
doanh Xong rồi ông ấy kinh doanh kiểu
đương nhiên là chưa biết kinh doanh ông
lại phá sản n m ông ấy không thất nghiệp
không làm được gì nên ông quay lại đi
làm đây tôi cảm thấy là có khi là do ông
ấy thất nghiệp quay lại đi làm chứ không
phải là vì ông ấy còn đam mê Cái ngành
này chứ Nếu giả sử mà để mà lựa chọn có
khi ông không chọn làm lại ngày ngày nữa
đâu thế nên là tôi mới cảm thấy là kiểu
có khi là đến đấy mình biết đâu Mình bị
giết chết đam mê Sao thế là tôi cũng hơi
rén bạn
đấy thì thì nhưng mà tôi vẫn muốn kiểu
chính ác là
tôi may mắn là tôi được sang nước ngoài
rồi
tôi được sang Singapore hồi mà đi dậy
thì có trường có đầu tư cho sang sinh và
Mai nhưng mà ấn tượng tôi tôi chẳng
thích gì bên sinh cả có một sự thật như
thế nó hơi bị nất như là tôi cái trải
nghiệm của tôi thôi Ngoài việc Có rất
nhiều trải nghiệm tốt ở bên đấy không
nói như đang nói là Nếu giả sử tôi được
sang sang đấy sống và làm việc chẳng hạn
Tôi cảm thấy là tôi sẽ không chọn cái
đấy kể cả cho dù lương mọi thứ đãi ngộ
có vẻ tốt như thế nào trừ khi nó phải
kiểu kiểu nhở Chắc nó phải gấp năm gấp
10 lần Bây giờ thì may ra chứ thực sự là
và đấy nếu mà như thế thì đúng nghĩa là
tôi đi vì gọi là bán mình có tư bản luôn
chứ không phải là vì mình thích nữa bởi
vì thật sự thì sang đấy tôi cảm thấy là
cái trải nghiệm rất tốt cho đến buổi tối
hôm đấy buổi tối hôm đấy tôi gặp một
người bạn đi cà phê một người bạn đang
làm việc ở bên
đấy cả một buổi 2 tiếng rưỡi đồng hồ bạn
ấy chỉ nói về tiền nên là mà trong khi
đó tôi kiểu một con người
không không đi Hoa về vật chất lắm nên
thành ra là kiểu cảm thấy là tôi sang
đấy tôi dễ bị tỉnh não kiểu dạng rất
nhiều người sang đấy tô Tôi đã từng đọc
vài bài thì đúng là người ta đánh giá là
bên đấy là đời sống mọi thứ đời sống
thực ra vật chất mọi thứ tốt nhưng Họ
sống cuộc sống ở đấy không phải là kiểu
cứ cứ nói như bên mình đấy Bên mình tính
ra vẫn là sứ sở Thiên Đường Là mình vẫn
hoàn toàn là làm mọi thứ mình thích được
đôi khi mình lác luật hay là mọi thứ
mình kiểu sự kiểu tự do ấy đấy bên đấy
thì bị áp lực rất nhiều nó n là giống
như là bên Nhật thôi tức là sang đấy
kiểu dạng mình bị áp lực rất nhiều và
mình sang đấy không tận hưởng cuộc sống
đâu Mình sang đấy C để cầy làm kiểu cầy
tiền nhiều nhất nhất có thể rồi mình té
nên là thành ra là kểu tôi không đánh ra
cao Nếu tôi sang đấy sống
nấy là tôi vẫn chưa được trải nghiệm gì
cả vẫn trên góc nhìn tôi nghĩa là toàn
bộ cái tâm sự tôi vẫn ở trên góc nhìn nó
hơi phiến diện một tí vì tôi vẫn trải
nghiệm rất là ít thì tôi cũng chỉ biết
chia sẻ lại những cái trải nghiệm về cái
quan điểm mình thôi còn nếu ông nào cảm
thấy là kiểu Ừ nó vẫn còn gọi là hạn chế
thì mấy ông có thể chia sẻ thì tôi được
mở mang từng
óc cái gì mở mang đầu óc nh tấm Mắt Đầu
óc anh đã bao giờ ghen tỵ với người giỏi
hơn mình
là
tôi Tôi từng nói mấy ông đó là tôi không
so sánh mình với người khác mấy mấy Tôi
chắc chắn là sẽ nhờ lúc mình so sánh
người khác ví dụ th đôi khi ở chỉn giả
là ngoại hình mình mình cũng đã so sánh
với người khác rồi Kiểu là kiểu Nhiều
lúc mình cũng tự ti kiểu dằng mình không
to khỏe như người ta hay là đẹp trai thì
không nói đẹp trai thì không thể nói đập
Khuôn mặt đi làm lại được Chắc chắn là
không ý định đấy cũng như là không không
có
kiểu Dạ nhở Ừ tôi không ý định ph thuẩn
mỹ hay gì cả không quan tâm điều đấy lắm
còn ghen tị về việc giỏi thì
cũng không hẳn đương nhiên là cũng cũng
cảm thấy tủi thân nếu mà giả sử là à
người khác
kiểu xuất xuất phát cùng bằng mình như
về sau hơn mình đấy Kiểu thế hoặc là chỉ
đơn giản chỉ đơn giản là tán không tán
được bạn nữ kia mà thằng kia tán được
đấy Kiểu thế mà trong khi đó mình cảm
thấy là mình ăn nó ở nhiều điểm nhưng mà
ừ đấy Kiểu thế thì có thể ghen tị nhưng
mà nhưng mà sau cùng thì tôi cảm thấy nó
sẽ một Tôi sẽ cố biến nó thành động lực
để tôi tự phấn đấu và tốt hơn cho bản
thân Hồi trước là tôi từng có một người
đúng nghĩa là có một người như thế đó là
một người mà tôi cảm thấy
là tôi phải bằng được giỏi hơn người đấy
Tôi không ghen tị người đấy nhưng mà tôi
đúng là
tôi rất kiểu dùng từ rất gét không
đúng nhưng mà tôi cảm thấy là kiểu bị nh
nà để tôi kể lý do đã nhá bạn đấy tế Bạn
biết tôi qua nhóm J team commit rồi Bạn
xin vào
à xin vào học ở trường tôi dạy nhưng mà
đương nhiên là không không vào lớp tôi
dạy mà vào lớp người khác Xong rồi bạn
đấy vẫn kiểu à Nhắn tin làm thân các thứ
thứ kiểu làm quen xong rồi Anh em thân
nhau khá nhiều thân đến nỗi là kiểu tôi
cũng từng bảo bạn ấy qua nhà tôi để mà à
Kiểu kiểu hôm nấy rủ về lý do gì cũng ăn
ngủ với nhau ngồi làm làm việc cùng nhau
luôn thế tôi thì tôi quan điểm là tôi
cũng không kiêng kiêng rè ai cả nên
thành kiểu một người lão hoắc mời về nhà
được như thế nhưng mà tôi cũng biết qua
hoàn cảnh của bạn đấy hoàn cảnh bạn đấy
cũng khá khó khăn nên là thành ra kiểu
cũng thương đấy xong rồi về sau thì bạn
ấy a bạn ấy kiểu tính bạn ấy kiểu muốn
ganh đua ấy Kiểu muốn bứt phá các thứ
thứ Nên là cũng thể hiện ra thì tôi cũng
hỗ trợ được bạn đấy kiểu dạng bạn có tư
duy có tầm nhìn nên là thành ra mình vẫn
hỗ trợ cho nên khi về sau biết được
những cái thứ nhất là tiếng xấu bạn đấy
Khi mà người khác kể ở tôi là bạn làm
mọi m thứ vì kiểu để kiếm tiền ấy mà
trong cái đó trái ngược của tôi là là
kiểu không con người không quan tâm Vật
chất thì tôi cảm thấy là cái tâm của bạn
đấy nó sẵn sàng giẫm đạp với người khác
để mà mình lên ấy chứ không phải ngược
lại là K có thể
à Có thể như nào nhỉ kéo được người khác
lên không bạn sẵn sàng dẫm đạp người
khác luôn đấy n là tôi không thích rồi
xong rồi về sau lúc mà lúc mà mà bạn đấy
thi cái giải gì ở trường hay gì gì đấy
Bạn được giải nhất X Lúc mà tôi biết
được ý tưởng Đấy là thứ ra ăn cấp từ Nói
thẳng luôn ăn cấp bởi vì bạn ấy tham gia
nhóm ch team community cái tưởng đ cái
tưởng tóm tắt bài viết viết bài báo
à Kiểu tóm tắt điểm
à gọi là điểm tin mỗi ngày đấy là của
hối trước là đầu tiên là của của anh
Tuấn Tôi thấy đầu tiên của anh Tuấn về
sau là của bên khác có thể là của bên
bên buýt hay gì gì đó thì tôi không biết
đại khái là thế sau rồi Bạn ấy cũng làm
cái sản phẩm cũng chỉ tương tự thế đấy
thì thứ nhất là ăn cắp ý tưởng chứ còn
để làm cái đấy Nói thẳng luôn là rất là
dễ thôi bỏ qua nhưng mà về sau là khi
mà tôi a chấm tôi đi dậy nên là tôi có
chấm a kiểu dạng là chấm đồ án cuối kiểu
nó có bọn tôi sẽ có B làm đồ án và bảo
vệ đồ án trước Hội đồng ấy thì tôi ở
trong hội đồng thì tôi chấm khi mà nói
chung là khi mà tôi dạy ấ Tôi sẽ không
bao giờ để nói chung là mình phải chuyên
nghiệp mình không bao giờ để cái
A cái gì nhỉ Cảm Xúc cá nhân ảnh hưởng
việc việc công và việc công việc tư việc
tư đúng không công tư phân mình th tôi
không để bị ảnh hưởng gì cả thì tôi vẫn
kiểu chấm Bạn ấy tôi vẫn chấm Bạn ấy để
10 như tôi hỏi những cái câu kiểu dạng
là khi nói chung là với sinh viên tôi
thì sẽ quen đó là chỉ là à với những
người giỏi thôi sẽ hỏi những câu toàn
hoàn toàn khác và hoàn toàn hóc khó cốt
là để mà hỏi kiểm tra trình độ thôi
Nhưng bạn ấy có vẻ thái độ khá là tự
kiêu Nhưng mà thực sự là tôi khi mà tôi
hỏi mấy câu đấy xong thì bạn ấy cũng
cũng không trả lời được xong rồi toàn
nói kiểu đá sang cái khác à kiểu dạng là
kiểu dạng công kích cá nhân ấy ông hiểu
không kiểu cứ nghĩ là tôi đang tôi đang
kiểu ghét bạn ấy hay là kiểu ghen tỵ với
bạn đấy Kiểu kiểu thế kiểu Tại sao thầy
l hỏi em mấy câu đấy các thử thử chẳng
hạn nên là tôi cảm thấy là người như này
thì sẽ không ổn Tôi đánh giá như thế
thôi đương nhiên là đến bây giờ may vẫn
ổn đỉnh
thật Nói chung là về sau khi mà tôi đi
dậy thì tôi biết được khi mà đi dậy thì
mình đang dậm chân tại chỗ bởi vì mình
không trải nghiệm ra ngoài mình va chạm
để nâng trình độ lên còn trong khi đó
người đấy thì trẻ hơn mình chén khá
nhiều tên người đấy còn rất giống tôi
nữa Cũng là Nguyễn Nam tôi không nói cụ
thể tên th Nhưng mà chắc chắn là người
đấy sẽ không bao giờ xem cái cái stream
này mà có thể người thân chắc không nhắn
gì đâu Chắc không ai biết đâu đại khái
thì
cũng kiểu gặt hái được khá nhiều thành
công nhưng mà tôi tôi đã từng hỏi rất
nhiều người làm chung nhóm mà nói với
người đấy thì đều bảo là họ kiểu dạng là
đấy như tôi bảo là có thể sẵn sàng kiểu
kiu vùi dập hay là kiểu lấy hay là nói
chung là không biết được bởi vì mình vẫn
không phải người trong cuộc đúng không ạ
th nĩ là mình vẫn chưa bao giờ là người
trong
cuộc để mà nên là thành ra là kiểu mình
không đánh giá được nhưng mà tôi vẫn nhớ
có một cái đó là
chứ nhầm hai cái mà tôi cảm thấy là tôi
không ba giờ chấp nhận được về cái đấy
Tôi sẽ gọi nó là thằng thì thường là tôi
sẽ tô luôn tôn trọng sinh viên của mình
tôi luôn xưng hô mấy ông luôn là tư cách
là kiểu không có vai vế gì cả nhưng là
tôi sẽ gọi đấy là thằng bởi vì nó không
xừng đạ là một Hằng đàn ông đối với
tôi thứ nhất đó là à Nói chung là mình
tôi không chưa từng đối xử tệ với với nó
nhưng mà nó từng Hình như là chắc chắn
nói xấu tôi với sếp của nó tôi biết được
bởi vì hồi đấy là Hồi đấy tôi đăng một
cái bài đăng tâm sự ở trên nhóm J2 team
community xong rồi đ Hỏi cái gì xong rồi
xế của nó vào chửi tôi Ừ hai người chưa
Giờ nói chuyện với nhau chưa Giờ quen
nhau đấy và chửi tôi ở trong cái bình
luận đấy à Kiểu kiểu may mà không phải
thằng Long dậy dậy à hay cái gì gì đó
Tôi nhớ
thế đấy Đấy là một Tôi chưa Giờ nói
chuyện với cái ông sếp kia chưa Giờ nói
chuyện thế mà sẵn sàng có một ông ở đó
vào bình luận nhóm công khai để mà chửi
mình Thứ nhất là ông đấy chắc chắn là
theo tôi cũng chả ra gì vì kểu thứ hai
chỉ có một người duy nhất có thể nói xấu
tôi chí thằng kia nên là tôi cảm thấy là
kiểu đấy là như
kiểu nói chung là có đương nhiên là có
thể có thể là tôi cũng vô tình làm gì đó
xấu không không biết
được Tôi nghĩ là vô tình vì tôi chắc
chắn là tôi sẽ không làm gì sau đặc biệt
là với sinh viên của mình tôi bảo công
tư nó vẫn là phụ công tư phân minh tính
Tôi không phải con người
kiểu dạng là kiểu đây đâm lén sau lưng
vân vân thích Nếu mà có vấn đề gì mình
nói thẳng với nhau thôi
à Nói chung là đại khái thế tôi đương
nhiên tôi chặn cái ông ông kia thôi sao
tôi chặn luôn cả nó tôi xin phép à anh
Tuấn là hồi đấy là tôi hơi lặ quyền đấy
là hình như là đấy lần duy nhất tôi lm
quyền tôi chặn luôn cả nó bởi vì tôi
biết thừa là chỉ có kiểu nó bơm đểu hay
là làm mọi thứ kiểu như thế thứ hai là
cái này là chuyện cái này là chuyện cá
nhân thế nh không liên quan gì bên nhóm
các thứ nữa rồi chuyện cá nhân đó là
bạn đấy à Tôi thích bạn đấy nhưng mà
cuối cùng về sau tôi vẫn không thể tán
được bạn ấy nói chung là không thành
thành ra về sau tôi thù Python với vs
code ấy cả thậm chí là đồ Apple nữa đấy
nhưng là đại khái là thế thôi Kiểu tán
bạn đấy Xong rồi không được thô thằng
này Thằng này hồi đấy là tôi cũng có
thân vẫn thân thằng này nên thằng ấy
biết thằng ấy cũng qua đấy Tán mệ luôn ạ
rồi còn xin về làm cùng công ty mậy luôn
đ không thế tôi vẫn nhớ cái của câu
không phải câu cuối nhưng mà tôi có nhớ
một lần nó nói vu
vơ Tôi cứ tưởng đùa nhưng về sau hóa ra
là thật đó là nó từng nói là em muốn
phấn đấu không phải để bằng anh mà để
hơn anh đấy nó có tiêu chí là như thế
Tôi cứ tưởng là nó chỉ là đùa theo kiểu
Ok kiểu em phấn đấu hơn anh thì tốt đúng
không Chẳng sao phải chó hơn thầy là tốt
nhưng có vẻ phấn đấu bằng cách là nó sẽ
kiểu tìm đấy mọ mọi cái kiểu như tôi vừa
nói thì nó tính cách của nó là kiểu là
vùi dập người khác xuống đấy xong rồi
bắt trước hay là làm mọi thứ kiểu theo
dõi mình là mọi xong rồi để mà cố gọi
như chứng tỏ nó sẽ đánh thắng mình
ấy đấy thức ra là khi mà ông bị cái tâm
là kiểu lúc nào cũng theo rõ người ta
kiểu cố ghen tị rồi Kiểu Tôi không biết
dùng từ ghen tị hay không thì tôi về các
bạn chẳng có thành công thành công gì
nhưng mà Đúng là bạn đấy Kiểu cũng cố đi
dậy r cố làm mọi thứ cái thứ thứ ná ná
kiểu như thế để mà chứng tỏ bản thân thế
có thể là bạn đấy Lúc đầu bạn coi tôi ở
một thần tượng xong rồi về sau kiểu cũng
muốn giống thần tượng hay gì gì có thể
thế chỉ đơn giản là một mốc gì nó phân
đấu nhưng mà nó bị cái cách đấy nó mấy
ông nghe nó rất là bị sai đúng
không nên là Thành A Tôi cảm thấy là hai
điểm Đấy là hai điểm Ờ hai điểm mà tôi
cảm thấy
là
tôi sẽ
kiểu coi Nó gần như kẻ thù thì hơi quá
Nhưng đại khái kiểu là một một cái gì đó
là chị không bao giờ Bây giờ mục đích
của ông đấy là muốn hơn tôi đúng không
Tôi cũng sẽ có mục đích đó làm chế tôi
sẽ phân đấu để không bao giờ nó thể đạt
được cái mục đích
sống như thế tôi cảm thấy ông sẽ luôn là
cái bóng người khác thôi luôn ở sau
người ta và nói xấu và luôn muốn đâm lén
hay gì đó rồi sớ như thế theo tôi thì nó
không biể tốt Mình sống cho chính mình
mình không sống vì một người nào đó
à Tôi cũng như thế Tôi cũng cố muốn tôi
từng có rất nhiều thần tượng chứ đến bây
giờ vẫn có có rất nhiều người tôi gọi là
đại ca rất nhiều người gọi tôi tôi gọi
là thầy
Ờ kiểu dạng là ừ kiểu dạng có người tôi
gọi là kiểu coi như là anh trai anh trai
ruột Hà nói các thứ thứ có người tôi coi
là em em trai ruột luôn tôi vẫn học hỏi
từ tất cả những người đấy học hỏi từ tất
cả những người xung quanh
À tôi không coi ai
là tôi không coi ai là kiểu dạng là một
cột mốc để mình cố phậ đấu ở thành mình
học hỏi từ tất cả những người xung quanh
cố tạo kết nối những người mà mình gọi
là không phải những người mà mình coi là
tốt đâu Thực ra là tôi Tôi ví dụ như hôm
trước ấy tôi vẫn có thể đi cà phê với
những bạn sinh viên mà đấy Nhắn tin ch
tôi tôi vẫn kiểu rủ bạn đi cà phê xem
tôi hỗ trợ đ gì bạn đấy không thì tôi có
thêm nhiều góp nhìn mới bạn ấy chẳng cần
phải dạy tôi gì cả chủ yếu hô hôm đấy là
tôi là người nói tôi hôm đấy tôi về nói
khản cả giọng luôn nói rất nhiều để mà
kiểu truyền lại những cái kiến thức hay
chia sẻ mọi thứ cho bạn đấy nhưng mà tôi
lại thêm góc nhìn của bạn đấy nữa cho
rồi bạn đấy nói rất là ít
đấy thế nên là tôi cảm thấy là tôi cũng
khá phù hợp khi mà đi cùng tôi cảm thấy
là tôi hướng ngoại nhưng mà chính ra là
tôi gọi nhở tôi lại khá ổn đi đi cùng V
mấy người hướng nội nhá Mấy người hướng
nội nói ít đúng không nhưng tôi nói tôi
nói nhiều hộ người ta ấy đấy các thử các
thứ Nên là họ cũng cảm thấy thoải mái
khi mà đi cùng thậm chí họ cũng về sau
họ cũng là người nói nhiều họ nói nhiều
vãi trưởng Tôi cảm thấy là cứ một khoảng
một khoảng thời gian nào đó Khi mà đi
cùng tôi tất cả mấy người hướng nội đấy
chuyển qua chế độ nói nhiều toàn nói hết
phần của tôi ạ tôi toàn bảo là kểu để ý
để em nói nào kiểu các thứ các thứ họ
chen vào họng Kơ để nói cơ Có thể họ khó
chịu khi nghe mình nói nhiều quá nhưng
mà tôi nghĩ là tôi đã bật được cái chế
độ khác của người ta lên con người khác
của họ
kẻo bị lạc mất bình luận ở đâu rồi
Ờ ấy như đại khái chỉ trả lời câu có
gent tị với ai chưa thì câu trả lời sẽ
là gần như là đối với tôi vẫn là không
tôi không gên thị gần như tuyệt đối mà
ai cả nhưng tôi sẽ có những cái người mà
tôi cố phấn đấu không phải để giỏi hơn
họ về tôi không so sánh gì cả mà tôi
thấy là học hỏi được hay là kiểu một cột
mốc gì đó giống như là hồi trước là tôi
cũng có một người bạn để mà bạn ấy cũng
rất là giỏi tôi rất là thầ tượng bạn ấy
thật mẹ Đúng con này người ta luôn nên
là tôi thường hay kiểu Chúng tôi thường
hay kiểu kiểu dạ cá với nhau là điểm lần
môn lần này tao sẽ điểm cao hơn mày ch
đơn giản thế cá 10.000 thôi đấy nhưng mà
kiểu anh em cùng nhau phân đấu phân kiểu
ganh đua ấy nó khá là
tô chỉ có biết m hào à x
xỉa chum Nga chuma gì nói ngược lại cham
Ngu
gì
mi Hảo mi hảo la Nói chung biết ít lắm
tôi đã học tí gì đâu thế nên là tôi mới
để đây là tôi sẽ học mà đây theo thứ tự
đấy là tôi sẽ phải học hết đố này ít
nhất là học xong Chính trỉ Sư phạm này
để dạy bên FPT đấy tôi cảm thấy có khi
là trong năm nay tôi không đi dạy được
ấy tôi phải học hết đúng không anh Tôi
còn phải À đúng rồi tôi C
mất học một khóa ID cơ
bản bên FA là bên F VT
đây nhưng là chắc cái này sẽ song song
với mấy cái này Ừ song song mấy cái này
Lúc mà tôi đi học cái này cũng sẽ là lúc
mà có thể là tôi sẽ không còn livestream
mấy nữa vì kiểu bị kiến lịch học ấy Nên
là chắc tôi sẽ thông báo mấy ôm
giở nghĩa là bỏ giấc mơ sang Nhật rồi
nên thành ra kiểu sẽ sang Châu Âu và
sang Trung chung thì đúng là có rất
nhiều thứ rồi mình học vì cái họ cảm
thấy là họ phải đi người ta thường ví
phải đi trước mình 50 năm đúng không ạ
Đấy Tôi cảm thấy là sang đấy sẽ rất
nhiều thứ học nhau mỗi tội bên đấy Kể cả
bên đấy có biết tiếng Anh nhá Tôi vẫn
nhớ là bên đấy có lòng tự tôn rất là cao
nên là thấy nghe kiểu kể cả biết tiếng
Anh nữa họ vẫn bắt bạn phải nói tiếng
tiếng của họ với họ thì họ mới nói
chuyện còn không thì họ kiểu dạng là
không không nói chuyện mấy kiểu kểu thế
nên là tôi cảm thấy
là tuy là mình cũng là mu đất nước có có
kiểu lịch sử rồi cũng lòng tự tôn các
thứ cũng đoàn kết các thứ nhá Nhưng tôi
cảm thấy là mình đang bị đang bị chia
rãy dần ấy tự mình chia rãy dần ấy Tôi
cảm thấy là mình mình phải khôi phục lại
được cái lòng tự tôn đấy nên là tôi rất
thích mấy cái kiểu những cái chương
trình hay là những cái mọi thứ đó Khôi
phục cái kiểu lịch sử này hay lòng tự
tôn mình đây này tôi nói thẳng luôn là
rất nhiều người b giờ biết lịch sử nước
ngoài đặc biệt là ví dụ Trung chẳng hạn
hay là Ừ chắc là Trung là nhiều nhất
mình xem phim cổ trang mà đấy nhiều hơn
cả lịch sử nước nhà đúng không ạ thì rõ
ràng là mình phải làm cách nào đó để
mình kiểu khác họa lại mọi thứ bằng cách
vào đó Nói chung là tôi nghĩ là mỗi cá
nhân mình tự mỗi cá nhân mình có lòng tự
tôn dần lên thì mình cũng đỡ hơn rồi Tôi
có lòng tự tôn rất là cao ví dụ mấy ông
thấy là tôi rất hạn chế bản tiếng Anh
chỉ khi mà dạy kiểu dạng nói mấy từ
tiếng nghĩ chuyên ngành thì tôi sẽ sử
dụng tiếng Anh không Tôi rất hạn chế nói
nửa anh nửa Việt mà tôi
kiểu nói chung là làm mọi thứ mình
vẫn kiểu gọi như là không thể nói là
mình kiểu yêu đạng yêu nhà nước hay là
kiểu gì đó một cách kiểu dạng sao rỗng
được đại khái thì mình mình sinh a lớn
lên ở đây rồi mình sử dụng ngôn ngữ này
mình sẽ cần phải thể hiện mình tự hào
với nó đúng không
ạ nhiều người vẫn còn bị xính ngoại Vân
Vân quá TH là
kiểu mình kể cả cho dù là
mình mình có đến giai đoạn nào đó bằng
bằng được nó đi thì mình vẫn sẽ bị thù
lùi sau với nó bởi vì lọc tự tôt nó về
cơ bản cao hơn mình cả ơn mình rất nhiều
t tôi thấy là thế tôi tiếp xúc cũng tiếp
xúc rồi nhưng mà mà chưa được à sang hẳn
đên đấy chứng kiến
để làm việc có ổn không nhỉ Ừ đ em nếu
mà học hỏi thêm cái gì đó nữa thì càng
tốt thì càng tạo cho mình thêm nhiều cơ
hội thôi Anh dùng max gì thế Mình dùng
Macbook
em1 đến thể hiện hiện tại thì nó vẫn
hoàn toàn tốt cho việc lập trình mọi thứ
các thứ 16 GB nhá Nhưng mà tôi vẫn nghĩ
là sau đợt Tết này tôi sẽ mua thêm con
ting bass để mà Thứ nhất là đi Dậy thì
phải dùng Win bởi chủ yếu vẫn nên dùng
Win để mà cho sinh viên quen được cái
giao diện vân vân và sử dụng được nhiều
phần mềm để mà hỗ trợ việc dạy thứ hai
đó là tôi sẽ cài song song cả linus để
mà tôi linus thì nó vẫn là tối yêu nhất
cho việc code các
lắm Tự nhiên tôi lại nhớ cái quả piu piu
piu piu là CT em có yêu rồi bây giờ em
phải làm thế nào thì em cũng có ng yêu
lúc này em sẽ kiểu nói lại với nó chẳng
qua tao yêu mày ta thương mày tao mới
kiểu muốn đến với mày thôi tao thiếu gì
kiểu đấy Mày có người yêu thì tao cũng
có người yêu không nhớ được có kiểu đầy
đủ gì nữa nhưng đại khái để giọng B B nó
như
cái đấy không kiểu nói nửa đùa nửa thật
đấy nhưng mà cái đấy sự thật đó là
ờ không Đương nhiên là ông vẫn nên lụy
tôi vẫn tôi vẫn coi tình tình yêu là một
thứ rất là thiên liêng không phải nói là
kiểu hôm nay nói yêu người này Hôm sau
nó yêu người khác được thì nó không phải
tình yêu nó một cái sự sáo rộn nhưng
mà nhưng mà Nếu giả sử thật sự ông muốn
hạnh phúc trong chuyện tình cảm không
phải nói ông nên luôn tìm lốp dự phòng
hay mọi thứ nhá mà nói là ông có thể su
sục một thời gian ông thể kiểu thật tình
một thời gian ông thể cứ lụy một thời
gian đi nhưng sau đó ông vẫn phải tự vực
dậy tự mình ổn vì tự mình có thể tự vực
mình Dậy thôi Làm gì ai cứu ông nữa và
nói chung là một là ông ông phải xác
định rõ một là ông Lụy theo kiểu dạng
như là anh chỉ yêu mình em giống như
kiểu nhiều bộ
phim thì một là đấy chấp nhận thì C thế
xong rồi ngắm nhìn cô đấy Hạnh phúc bên
người kia hoặc là cố chiếm lại cô đấy
tùy hai đó
là xác định tư tưởng là phải bước tiếp
và Bước tiếp thì bước tiếp thôi đúng
không đấy tùy m ông
chọn nếu mà ông cảm thấy sng không thể
thiếu cô đấy cô oxy của ông thì ông chọn
cách một còn không thì người ta
không không quan trọng mình đến thế thì
mình cũng gọi nhờ Tự mình tự mình kiểu
dạng
là khiến nó mình đau khổ thôi vì rõ ràng
là mình vô hình cho mất người ta
mình nhưng mình vẫn nghĩ bạn ấy đùa và
gần đây mình vào Facebook thì s lại ho
tôi nhớ hồi trước tôi cũng tưởng bị thế
Nó là kiểu t Nhưng mà lúc đầu tôi tưởng
thật Xô về sau bạn ấy nói tôi là thực ra
bạn ấy cũng chỉ muốn làm tôi g thôi
nhưng mà gọ
nhỉ kể cả trong trường hợp của tôi hay
trường hợp của ông nhá thì mình luôn coi
nó là một sự nghiêm túc đi vì Nếu giả sử
mình đã coi là nghiêm túc rồi đúng không
Thì mình sẽ luôn coi nó nghiêm túc Kể cả
bạn kia có đùa nữa thì với tôi thì không
bao giờ đùa chuyện đấy khi mà tôi đã coi
nó nghiêm túc thì người kia coi đùa thì
hai người đã suy nghĩ khác nhau rồi đúng
không ạ Đấy nó n nào giống như việc chơi
game ấy th tự nhên liên quan một tí nó
kiểu chơi game ấy sẽ rất nhiều lúc chơi
game chắc là mấy ông kiểu gì chẳng từng
chơi mấy cái em đồng đội đúng không ạ
thì hai người cùng tư tưởng tức cả là
hai người cùng chơi game v kiểu vui vẻ
Ok mày kiểu tấu Hai chơi game này giái
trí tao cũng chơi game tấu Hai giái trí
suy ra cả hai không vũi đúng không hoặc
là tao coi game này rất là nghiêm túc
tao coi kiểu dạng Tuy là chơi để vui
Nhưng mà tao không hẳn là tôi tao coi
Chiến Thắng là tất cả đâu có nhiều người
như thế thì thực ra không nên không tốt
đ lắm Nhưng mà tao coi rất nghiêm túc
tao muốn kiểu trai h muốn hết sức mình
đúng không Thì cái đồng đội của ông cũng
nên phải kiếm cái người cũng kiểu cùng
chí hướng như thế thế Tự nhiên một người
cố hết sức một người cật nhả thì bản
thân ông khó chịu thôi đúng không ạ Và
thậm chí thằng kia khó chịu thôi thằng
kia sẽ quay tại sao mày nghiêm túc thế
đấy Kiểu thế Nói chung là ở trong một
mối quan hệ nó na ná như thế nó kiểu cả
hai phải nhìn nhận một vấn đề nó phải
cùng tương đương nhau còn không thì kể
cả Nói chung là theo tôi quan điểm nhé
Hôm trước từng có người hỏi tôi một câu
đó là cái này liên quan đế chuyện tình
cảm đó là kiểu
chưa hoặc là hoặc là kiểu
anh Ừ hình như là câu đấy thôi phải đấy
Kiểu thế
thì thì theo tôi trong một quan hệ bản
chất là bọn
tôi Bọn tôi kiểu gần như là tôi sẽ tôi
chừ trước nay chỉ có hai kiểu một là tôi
tán bạn ấy không đủ hay là tôi tán được
bạn đấy hoặc là bạn ấy chủ động mở đên
xanh bằng cách h gì gì đó Nhưng mà
thường Gần đây tôi có nói với ông rồi
không có chuyện ông tán V người ta chẳng
qua người ta bật lên Xong xanh cho mình
thôi đấy
thì khi khi mà ông nghĩa làm chể là gần
như ông không khái niệm tán người ta bởi
bởi vì ít khi mà biến cái không thành có
lắm một khi người ta đã không thích mình
rồi từ chối mình rồi còn như là không
không biến lại ngược lại được đấy nên
thành ra khi mà ông bước vào mối quan hệ
thì ý ý tôi nó làm chị ạ một là ông bước
và mối quan hệ Đấy rất là dễ dễ Bởi vì
ông nói thẳng luôn là ông rất là nh nhặt
nhẽo người ta vẫn bật đành xanh ông rồi
nế Ông vẫn bước vào được hai là người ta
chặn lô BC tường rồi không thể bước vào
được đấy C một khi bước vào được rồi Thì
lúc đấy mới gọi là cái khó Ý tôi là như
thế Một là rất là khó nhá kiểu tỷ lệ %
ấy một cái là 100 ph luôn ấy cứ chò 100
đi nhá kh không bước vào được mối quan
hệ rồi nhá Thì lúc đấy mới gọi là cái
khó nó bắt đầu mới xảy ra đó lúc mà mình
sẽ có rất nhiều điểm không tương động có
thử thử thế nên là quan điểm với tôi
việc tán gái chưa bao giờ khó cả
vậy chỉ có người hợp hayy không hợp một
người mở đèn xanh một người không mở
đúng không ạ Mình chỉ cần tìm được đúng
người mở đèn xanh thôi là được chứ không
phải là cứ lao đầu vào người mà không
hợp s v kêu là toàn g khó không
đấy thì khi mà ông tìm được người hợp
rồi thì cái việc ở trong một quan hệ Đấy
duy trì một quan hệ Đấy và một quan hệ
Đấy nó đem lại cho mình những cái gì đem
lại cảm xúc hay đem lại động lực để làm
việc hay mọi thứ đấy các thứ nó nó phù
hợp các thứ cái đấy mới là cái khó chứ
nó chứ nó chưa bao giờ với tôi với Tôi
cần nhận ra được cái chân lý đấy Đó là
việc tán con gái chưa giờ khó
mấy ông sẽ biết cách kiểu dễ sống hơn
đấy tôi Tôi nghĩ là nó dễ sống hơn nó là
nào giống như kiểu bây giờ ông học đấy
ông học lập trình web rồi tự nhiên ông
cứ cố Cố ứng tuyển vào m cái cái công ty
không làm về web Xong rồi ông bảo Tại
sao khó
thế thì có phải tự ông khiến Cuộc sống
khó khăn hơn đúng không chẳng khác gì C
đúng không Đấy ông biết ngôn ngữ chung
thì ông lấy cứ đăng ký vào cng tuyển một
cái công ty toàn bằng tiếng anh Sa lại
bảo là tại sao công ty này trảnh thế
công ty này các thứ đòi hỏi cao thế Thế
là dở
rồi
gắng nữ à Không tôi thực ra không nói
chuyện với bạn ấy nữa rồi nó chúng là
kiểu nói chung là cũng từ rất lâu rồi
đại khái thì mình không nên để những cái
cảm xúc tiêu cực đấy bởi tính là thực ra
tôi có một con người cũng gọi là nghĩ
nhiều thì cũng có Tôi nghĩ ai bây giờ
cũng cần như cũng bị bệnh tâm lý chung
là nghĩ
nhiều nên là mình cố hạn chế nhất làm
những cái khác các thứ
toàn xịt tại sao tự nhiên Đợt này em lại
muốn em Phả nhảy Ừ đương nhiên là nên
nhảy sau Tết chắc là các bạn thường là
nhảy sau Tết nhưng mà Chính vì lượng
người cũng suy nghĩ nhảy sau tết nhiều
quá n th nghe là kiểu bây giờ cạnh tranh
cao lắm n nà giống như kiểu bây giờ bạn
đi A bây giờ bạn mới bắt đầu đi tìm thuê
phòng trọ cho sinh viên chẳng hạn Ừ bây
giờ kiểu sau Tết là chắc chắn là hết
phòng đúng không ạ Nên là một là bạn
phải ứng tuyển sớm làm sớm hai là phải
đợi phải chấp nhận đợ đợt sau chứ không
Bây giờ là tỉ lệ chọi cao mà mẹ ông cứ
liên quan đến việc cứ hình dung liên
quan Việc thuê phòng trọ sinh viên ấy vì
mấy ông là đang là sinh viên mà đúng
không Thường mấy ông thuê phòng trọ vào
khoảng thời gian nào thường mấy ông đặt
vé về quê Đặt vé máy bay về các thứ thứ
vào khoảng thời gian nào thì mấy ông
phải làm cái đấy tương đương Chứ m ông
đặt vào những cái không giờ và những cái
thời điểm khó khăn kiểu đông người đặt
thì tự mình lại đấy tự mình lại lại làm
khó bản thân thôi đúng không
Macbook em1 làm react native cho is ok
không mọi người Tôi thấy là kiểu rất
nhiều anh em dùng Macbook M1 này vẫn
ngồi code các thứ ồn nế là
tôi tôi thấy nó một khoản đầu tư ổn nếu
Giả sử bạn chưa có nó ổn hơn rất nhiều
rất là ổn so với tầm cùng cái tầm giá
đấy so với laptop Windows thậm chí là cả
ví dụ tôi B giờ đang dùng đến nỗi Tôi
cảm thấy là nó phải Nếu mà so bên
Windows Chắc là nó phải lên đến Hạ ví dụ
Con này mua là cứ cho là mua là 18 đến
22 thì phải chng mà chắc chắn là phải
tầm đến 30 Nếu mà laptop Windows Tôi
đánh giá bây giờ như thế như Laptop
Windows ngoài ngoài ngồ code ra nó sẽ có
những điểm lợi khác tôi không đề cập m
Nói chung về mỗi lập trình thì tôi cảm
thấy là thế còn à đương nhiên là nếu mà
Giả sử bạn giống như là đây tôi cảm thấy
là kiểu 16 GB là không đủ chẳng hạn hay
là kiểu M1 nó vẫn cảm thấy dùng một thời
gian Tôi vẫn cảm thấy là nó vẫn chưa đủi
thỏa mãn tôi tôi vẫn muốn kiểu nhanh hơn
nữa đấy
thì lúc đấy thì chắc là cũng thứ nhất là
bây giờ vẫn đủ dùng nhá Bây giờ bạn mua
vẫn hoàn toàn đủ dùng giả giả sử Giả sử
là bạn mua xong rồi nó không còn đủ dùng
chong 2 năm nữa chẳng hạn thì bạn hoàn
toàn có thể kiếm được nhiều hơn so với
số tiền Bỏ ra trong vòng 2 năm nữa đ để
bạn nâng cấp cái con laptop nữa đúng
không ạ Và Macbook về cơ bản Nếu mua mới
bán bán lại vẫn được giá nên thành ra là
vẫn thoải mái Nên theo tôi thì tôi vẫn
sẽ đề xuất bạn là bây giờ có thể mua
luôn
được à Tôi không quảng cáo cho bên nào
nên chắc mấy ông cũng thấy nó uy tín hơn
đúng không ạ
Ờ bết lel biết một thêm một frame ja
Script thì nên học view hay react vậy
thường là nhiều người vẫn bảo theo view
Thật ra như tôi đã nói là ngôn ngữ nó
vẫn chẳng quan trọng và r view với react
Có rất nhiều điều điểm tương đồng nên là
bạn học cái nào cũng được để mà và về
sau nhảy sang cái nào cũng được nên rất
là thoải
bị nhiều quá bị thừa ấy tôi chẳng dù rồi
mấy ông có cài thêm cái gì không mấy ông
đị lưu cái gì video để mà ngồi cầy
render các thử
mà điền hình anh list Tôi vẫn đang cài
dùng bình thường
mà anh ơi sinh viên mới ra trường thì đi
Lương gỡ fesser như thế nào là ổn ạ Nếu
chọn mức Min luôn thì anh nghĩ là em cần
nên xem cái bài gần đây trên bên J2 team
có chia sẻ hai bài một bài bài à cách
phỏng vấn để mà nói chung về cách phỏng
vấn và một bài là về cách điu lương để
mà kiểu nâng lương bản thân lên cả hai
cái bài đều rất là cô động rất là à cô
động thì hơi quá bởi vì tôi vẫn sẽ dùng
từ cô động bởi vì nó đều nói trọng tâm
đều rất là
hay lối văn viết rất là hay nhưng mà
nhưng mà không thể dụng cũng có thể nó
nó không cố động bởi vì bài khá là dài
nhưng mà đọc cuốn lắm nên là hay cực em
thể lên để mà xem còn bây giờ anh cầu
bây giờ anh cũng không thể mở Facebook
được bây giờ vì hình như anh đăng xuất
tài khoản rồi Kiểu máy tôi hay là do
mạng ấ nó cứ tự động đăng xuất tài khoản
ra
rồi muốn nhảy vì công ty trải quá Ờ thế
thì khó bây giờ vẫn là bài toán cơm gáo
gại tiền mà C cứ ở ở lại để mà kiếm tiền
đã xong rồi mình vẫn tranh thủ nộp phỏng
vấn CV xong rồi Ờ kiểu tự cải thiện bản
thân là làm thêm Project các thứ các
rồi Bài này bài Tôi cũng không nhớ nó
cái gì c ơ tôi đăng nhập được rồi
sớm hơn à tôi lưu lại cái link này hám
chỉ để anh em có thể vào đọc nhá Nhưng
chứ không phải để tôi tâm sự gì cả anh
chọn sự y sự nghiệp hay tình yêu và Làm
sao để cân bằng hai thứ cù một lúc ạ
chính tôi đ từng hỏi câu này cho À tôi
không hỏi cái vế đầu mà cái vế sau là
làm th nào để cân bằng cân bằng đây như
không phải mỗi tình yêu mà cân bằng với
sự nghiệp với các mối quan hệ
Đấy thứ nhất là bây giờ để mà nói tôi
vẫn sẽ chọn là không phải sự nghiệp tôi
không dùng từ sự nghiệp mà tôi nói là để
cho kiểu tôi bây giờ tôi cái tiêu chí
của tôi vẫn là à phát triển bản
thân vì tính là sự nghiệp tôi về cơ bản
thì nó vẫn gọi là đang đủ để sống Thực
ra sống rất là tốt nếu mà giả sử chỉ
sống một mình
Ờ nhưng mà tôi quan tâm vẫn là phát
triển bản thân thì mình phải phát triển
bản thân hơn thì sự nghiệp Mình sẽ thăng
tiến hơn n Mọi thứ vẫn ổn hơn mà đúng
không ạ Đấy và tư duy tầm nhìn mọi thứ
nữa thái độ hay tính cách mọi thứ mình
nữa nên là tôi thế nên là tôi mới có một
loạt cái học vừa nãy tôi không Tôi còn
chẳng nhiều người còn thường anh Nó là
kiểu phải từ cái này suy ra kiểu học
xong cái này kiểu bỏ Ngần này tiền cho
học chong cái này chẳng hạn thì nó sẽ
suy ra nó sẽ hỗ trợ được cho công việc
mình tăng lên bao nhiêu phần trăm lương
hay gì gì đó Tôi nhớ thế Nó kiểu nó bị
th thực dụng quái thực tế quái thì tôi
còn không làm vấy cái đấy Nhưng tôi tin
là cải thiện mấy cái kia xong kiểu gì
kiểu gì thì cũng sẽ có chỗ cho mình nói
chung là gần như là tôi đã bỏ qua cái
giai đoạn mà nghĩ rằng là tôi phải kiếm
một cái chỗ nào đó để mà sống
để mà kiếm được việc các thứ thứ rồi
Chắc là may mà tội rất may mắn là kiểu
có rất nhiều cơ hội nên thành ra kiểu
cũng không nghĩ đế điều đấy nữa không
bận tâm về điều đấy nữa đương nhiên là
bây giờ chưa bị cơm máo gạ tiền chia
phối chi phối ch kiểu còn liên quan gia
đình nữa chắc là chưa nên là trong thời
gian này tôi chỉ muốn phát triển bản
thân là điều kiện Kiên kiết quan trọng
nhất còn về sự còn tình cảm thì nếu mà
đến thì thực ra mình vẫn sẵn sàng mình
không từ chối nhưng mà mình không ưu
tiên nó và nó nên là cái động lực gì đó
để hỗ trợ cho mình về cái việc phát
triển bản
thân thế nên là về việc cân bằng hai thứ
cùng một lúc thì về cơ bạn nghe các bạn
nghe tôi vừa nói thì nó sẽ chẳng có gì
cân bằng cả nghĩa là tôi sẽ thiên về cái
kia rất nhiều thiên về phát triển bản
thân hơn rất nhiều với tôi thì chuyện
tình cảm thì nó cũng khá là cái tôi cảm
thấy nó khá bất ổn nhất đối với tôi nên
là tôi
sẽ và tôi còn bị ảnh hưởng bởi chuyện
tình cảm khá nhiều Nói chung là tôi tôi
có thể nói tôi có người lý chí nhưng mà
tôi cũng sẽ bị cảm xúc chi phối khá
nhiều thành ra là tôi sẽ có rất nhiều
lúc à Ví dụ ngay hôm nay tôi cũng khá
bất ổn về tâm lý nhưng mà thực ra mấy
ông thấy tôi vẫn đang cố giữ nó đấy đấy
chắc là đối tôi Tôi nghĩ là thôi có thể
thể chuyên nghiệm một phần lúc mà đi dậy
nó như thế tâm lý hôm nay rồi Khá bất ổn
nhưng mà có thể mày không không cảm nhận
được điều đấy có thể thế Thế tính ở
chuyên nghiệp chưa ạ tôi từng đi dậy mà
vẫn phải giữ được cho mình cái gọi rạch
dòi cái mọi thứ chứ Công cái việc tư
việc cá nhân của mình mình không thể để
ảnh hưởng đ người khác được đúng không ạ
đặc biệt là không ảnh hưởng đế sinh viên
hay mọi thứ của mình được đấy
à đại khái là nếu mà bị bất ổn như thế
Tôi sẽ tạm né tránh à hay là nói chung
là tạm Giúp mình giải thoát khỏi mấy cái
tiêu cực các thứ thứ để mình tập trung
vào những thứ mình đang làm tránh để bị
ảnh
Hồi trước là tôi từng dạy
ở tôi từng dạy ở trường BK trường Kiểu
Học viện về công nghệ thông
tin các bạn muốn xem tiểu sử Chắc là lên
Facebook thì sẽ có nhiều hơn nhá đây tôi
tạo xóa đống ID này à Tôi sẽ để lại một
cái quên mất tôi sẽ để lại cái trên cùng
cho mấy ông để mấy
ơ
ơ tự nhiên là bây giờ não mất rồi đây
tôi Vừ quên phím tắt ạ â chưa
cái này mấy ông thể
xem cái này là gì Tôi không nhớ lắm
nhưng mà chắc là thôi bây giờ tạm Không
xem gì
thường có có viết bằng phải viết bằng
Framework không nên viết bằng Framework
dùng từ phải ca tráng công ty ở phải có
rất nhiều công ty giờ vẫn đang dùng
những cái công nghệ lỗi thời Nhưng mà
nếu mà bạn vào những công ty dùng lỗi
thời thì bạn
H vọng là bạn học hỏi được cái gì đó
thường là tôi thấy là những cái công
nghệ đối Thời đấy xếp chắc chắn là có
vấn đề nên khó học hỏi từ sếp nên học
hỏi từ nhân viên Nếu mà nhân viên mà
cũng không có gì học hỏi được họ vẫn
chấp nhận những cái dự án tồi Thế thì
bạn nên cân nhắc là dạng sang công ty
khác bởi vì tính trừ khi công ty đấy
lương đãi ngộ Mọi thứ rất là ổn nhưng mà
đôi khi Chính vì ổn như thế
nhá đôi khi Chính vì rất nhiều của tôi
nó khái niệm này khái niệm về an toàn à
đây hôm trước tôi có chia sẻ với cái bạn
sinh viên của
tôi
đó thực sự thế nào là an toàn
xong rồi kiểu dạng là thấy là bây giờ
mình đã có công việc rất nhiều công ty
giờ đang sát Hải dần mình chưa bị sát
Hải đúng không Mình đang gọi là an toàn
gọi là an toàn hơn Khá nh nhiều người vì
mình có công việc khá là ổn định rồi
Nhiều người bây giờ còn kiểu không biết
kiếm tiền thế nào để mai có cái ăn hay
cái gì gì đó nó hơi bị bi quan nhưng có
thể thực tế như thế thì mình đang đang
an toàn rồi không với tôi thực ra an
toàn Nó chỉ là một cái cảm giác mình tự
sinh mình tự rối lòng mình tự sinh ra để
lừa mình thôi thực sự làm gì có cái gì
an toàn thế một công ty Bây giờ vẫn thể
phá sản bất cứ lúc nào chứ đừng nói đ
nhân viên đ đúng không ạ Trừ khi ông
phải đến một cái cột mốc và kiểu là ông
là một mí rất là quan trọng nên công ty
không thể đuổi được
Ông Ông không phải cái mí đấy thì nó
chẳng có gì gọi an toàn cả đúng không
ạ Ông chỉ cảm thấy ông nghĩ rằng là ông
đang kiếm tiền thì B giờ gọi an toàn
nhưng mà giả sử Giả sử công ty không
đuổi ông nhá Giả sử thế đi V sao cũng
không thể nhảy sang công ty khác được vì
cái trình độ năng lực của ông nó chỉ đến
thế khi mà ông ở cái môi trường
không thể phát triển bản thân lên được
Ông ở một công ty rất là tồi ông không
học hỏi được cái gì cả Đây xong rồi xong
một vài năm nữa công ty có vấn đề như
này nếu mà công ty mà kiểu không phát
triển như thế thì công ty Kiểu gì nó
cũng sẽ đi xuống
thôi Lúc ông muốn nhảy ông không có một
cái con đường nào để ông nhảy vì bản
thân ông từ trước nay ông dẫn chân tại
chỗ quá lâu rồi nên là nên là kiểu tất
cả người khác họ tiến xa bỏ xa ông rồi
ông bây giờ ông muốn nhảy cũng chẳng
nhảy được thế đâu còn gọi an toàn nữa
đúng không ạ Ông đang đang tự gọi là
chôn chân một chỗ gọi là kiểu giống kiểu
cắt lún ý ông lún và quá sâu rồi ông tự
chôn bản thân ông ở đấy
Không tôi cảm thấy là
Ờ thứ nhất là tuổi trẻ mình không nên ổn
định cố định ở một chỗ giống như hôm
trước tôi từng kể đó là tôi gặp anh Minh
mon men anh ấy bảo là em nửa may nửa
không may à là khi mới ra trường khi mà
mới nghỉ dậy xong kiểu kinh nghiệm thực
tế chưa có mấy mà đã được vào một công
ty startup rất là ổn Bây giờ vẫn đang
phát triển vẫn tiềm năng các xếp mọi thứ
đều rất thuận lợi cho em phát triển rất
là tốt nhưng mà Đấy đấy là cái may những
cái dở đó là vì nó quá tốt nên em đang
muốn kiểu an phận ở đây
kiểu tiếp tục lâu dài đấy Tôi từng nói
mấy ông có thể làm làm đến kiểu khi nghỉ
hưu nghỉ hưu cái ngành này ngành làm IT
thôi nhưng mà chắc là vẫn sẽ chuyển
hướng sang đi làm diễn giả đi dậy hay gì
đó xong nhưng mà
Ờ vì vì thế nên Thanh An nó lại bị an
toàn quá theo kiểu là sẽ ít va chạm các
thứ thứ sẽ s không có thể chia sẻ được
rất nhiều góc nhìn bởi ít va chạm nhiều
công ty mà nế không có có cái góc nhìn
thực tế
đấy thế nên là nó lại biến thành không
an toàn tức là về sau khi mà đi dậy hay
là diễn giả tôi sẽ khó chia sẻ được rất
nhiều gấp nhìn nó khó mà khuyên được
sinh viên vì mình thực tế mình có trải
nghiệm được mấy đâu đấy thế thực sự Cái
nào là an toàn và nhà nước là an toàn à
Không vào đấy đấu đá vào đấy chính trị
đấu đá kinh khủng mà ông vẫn Coi an toàn
ông chạy tiền vào đấy Ông vẫn thể bị ra
Ui nói cái này Nó bị nhạy cảm quá không
nhỉ Như Tại ông Tại ông cố mớm tôi trước
nhá Ừ về sau mình cẩn thận cái miệng
mình không miệng mình đi xa lắm sợ thật
Tự nhiên có ông nào đó và nói mớm mình
cái xong rồi mình nói đứ nh nói góp nhìn
cá nhân thôi nhưng mà
kiểu
Ừ kiểu ciểu dạng là mình vẫn nhỏ bé chưa
có tâm ảnh hưởng nhưng mà mấy câu đấy
Đúng là có thể đi xa thật sợ thật Chắc
phải chạ ở ngoài
thôi thật tự nhiên c Đấy giống như kể
anh Độ à Anh độ kể livestream tự nhiên
thầy VTV24 và bình luận
quan tâm Bây giờ tôi quan tâm về sau về
sau có rất nhiều người kiểu về sau nổi
xong rồi những cái video cũ họ không nhớ
họ không để ý đấy xôi bị bới lại ui chết
tôi thế nên là cái anh leader của tôi
mới bảo là
kiểu mới mới bảo là kiểu anh ấy không
muốn là người nổi tiếng vì mồm An rất
nhiều lúc đi xa so về sau kiểu lúc mà
nổi rồi kiểu người ta đào lại mình cái
đây Chết chết chắc luôn
th lúc đấy thì nó còn tệ hơn cả việc
không nổi đúng không kiểu cứ bình Bình
Bình thì nó sẽ bình yên anh ạ tên là
Bình luôn
mà không thì đi xa lắm ông B ông đừng có
nhắc gì chính trị nhạy cảm nhá Tôi tôi
cũng kiểu bị cuốn quá tôi đi theo chết
mà đặc biệt là tất cả nhà báo khi mà cắt
thế nó sẽ không cắt đầy đủ đúng không ạ
Không Cắt đầy đủ những cái tôi đang
trình bày đâu nó chỉ cắt đúng một hai
câu thôi
đấy hay các thứ đi xa cực ô Ông làm sao
Ông Ông đăng lên 10 cái video Đình Chính
không nổi được bằng những cái bài báo
chia sẻ nó gìm ông kiểu vãi chưởng
luôn lúc đấy thì đương nhiên là người
biết mình thì họ kiểu cũng sẽ cố bên
mình hay cố bảo vệ mình nhưng mà người
không biết mình thì đông lắm Có một sự
thật như thế đó là
người người kiểu dạng là
người gọi như nào nó là hồi trước là tôi
đọc một cái đó là chúng ta có thể sẵn
sàng kiểu giết chết dùng tể giết chết
cũng đúng bởi vì vô hình vô hình nó là
con dao có thể giết chết người ta người
lạ trên mạng các thứ các thứ đúng không
ạ bể về cơ bản thì mình mình có có cái
gì đó gọi là cắn bó hay có trách nhiệm
gì đó quá với người ta đâu như nên thành
ra mình có thể bình luận hay là chia sẻ
những cái vui vui mình cảm thấy là kiểu
nó cũng kiểu gì gì đó ở trên mạng nhưng
mà vô tình có thể hại chết người khác có
nên là cái mạng xu hội Mọi thứ nó vẫn
rất là nguy hiểm đúng không ạ Đấy Đó nó
nguy hiểm mà bây giờ Giả sử có rất nhiều
bài báo đă tin sai về người khác bạn
thấy có rất nhiều Xong rồi Nếu mà khi mà
có bài đính khi mà người ta đinnh chính
người ta Minh Hoan nối mấy bài bạn tôi
thấy có ít ít trang báo đấy đăng lại cái
đính chính lắm mấy ông ông đã từng thấy
có trang báo và đăng đính chính không có
đăng xin lỗi không Ông có nhớ được cái
người đăng à Cái người ghi mấy cái bài
báo mà từng kiểu kiểu dạng là hãm hại
người kia không mấy ông có nhớ những cái
tác giả những cái bài báo đấy không thậm
chí có khi nó ghi ẩn danh nó cố né đúng
không ạ Đấy nên là thành ra kiểu chúng
ta hoàn toàn thể giết người khác các thứ
các thử thế Tôi đã từng nghe rất nhiều
người nổi tiếng chết bởi những cái tin
đồn người nổi tiếng thế giới của nó nhá
rất là nổi luôn chết vởi những ên đồn
của các báo chí rồi các bạn Thể tra trên
mạng rất nhiều mang tiếng là may thời
đại này thời đại công nghệ chính mình có
tiếp cận được công nghệ chính mình có
thể tự đăng cái Facebook của mình hoặc
tự đăng cái Twitter mình trừ khi ở kiểu
bị tổng thống nào đó bị chặn
mõm phải tự tạng mạng xã hội để đăng thứ
Nếu không thì không thì rõ ràng
rõ ràng là hoàn toàn là có thể kiểu
người ta cắt được mình đấy bây giờ cắt
mạng tôi chẳng hạn tôi bây giờ tôi thể
đăng mạng x hội khó khăn hơn các thứ
cho bài báo rồi
nói hãy để cho nó trôi đi ạ Chứ không ai
xem
tiêu đề rồi tiêu đề kiểu theo tên của
tôi ấ ví dụ giáo sư à già sư Nguyễn Nam
Long Thực ra tôi nghe Không Ngai lắm
Thực ra tôi cảm thấy là ví dụ gì nh Thạc
sĩ Nguyễn Nam Long là nghe tôi lại nghe
thấy ổn nhất tiến sĩ Nguyễn Nam Long tôi
nghe không ổn lắm lắm cơ nó bị cân cấn
ấy thế Tôi nghĩ là tôi sẽ chỉ học lên
Hạc sĩ thôi vì nghe thế Nghe tên vẻ Đẹ
kiểu Thuận mồm nghe nó đọc được
nhất
nói thật mấy ông mấy ông thử nói tên của
mấy ông ấ theo cái kiểu mấy cái tiêu đề
đấy xem mấy ông thích cái tiêu đề nào
nghe nó kiểu oai nhất đấy xong mấy ông
cố phấn đấu để đạt được cái tiêu đề đấy
à không phải tiêu đề cái kiểu danh hiệu
đấy đúng
của thầy toán cũng có tầm 100.000 Follow
mà trong group kí xong thầy lỡ chia sẻ
quan điểm cá nhân qu là sau comment
hướng khác hóa th thấy phải xó live
trong nội dung mà luôn đúng kiểu đôi khi
là mấy ông chia sẻ góc nhìn nó vẫn kiểu
rất là ổn nhưng mà người khác bình luận
và Nó bị nhạy cảm mình cũng bị ảnh hưởng
chứ Đấy sao thậm chí là lại bảo bảo là
kiểu cái ông thầy này định hướng định
hướng sinh viên các thứ các thứ để cho
sinh viên nói những câu thế uôi chết nên
là nên là đấy thế nên là tôi bảo mấy ông
mà cứ lái sang Chính thị là tôi cứ phải
chặn mấy ông trước đã để một là để phòng
cái mồm nó đi quá xa hai là chính mấy
ông đi quá xa rồi Tôi cũng bị vạ lây sợ
thị trường việc làm rất khó khăn kiếm
việc mới không dễ nhưng công ty hiện tại
Tệ quá đồng nghiệp tô xích tôi hôm trước
tôi cò Nói mấy ông về ba cái quan điểm à
Ba cái tiêu chí của Ờ anh minm men nói
về khi mà tìm công việc ấy một là lương
rất là hấp dẫn hai là ngĩa là đãi ngộ
Nói chung là đãi ngộ đãi ngộ Rất là hấp
dẫn hai là đồng nghiệp và sếp bởi vì có
một sự thật là ông không thay đổi sếp
chỉ có sếp thay đổi được ông thôi đấy và
đồng nghiệp cũng thế Thế Thành ra là
kiểu làm môi trường đấy ông kiểu đặc
biệt Làm bây giờ chủ yếu vẫn là offline
ít làm kiểu remote mà làm remote thì
thực ra vẫn làm với người khác mà đấy
thì
à Thì ông sẽ kiểu phải phải kiểu sống
cùng người ta bởi vì tính là cũng kiểu 8
tiếng một ngày nếu mà trung bình là như
thế đúng không ạ mất mất 1/3 ngày rồi để
làm việc cùng người ta phải đau não cùng
người ta thậm chí là làm đôi khi làm quá
giờ ấy Nếu giả sử không giải quyết được
công việc đúng không
ạ đau não Tôi cảm thấy ví dụ tôi vui về
công việc hiện tại vì tôi đau não với
đúng người đấy người ta sẽ C sếp hay
đồng nghiệp nó vẫn hỗ trợ được mình giả
sử mình đau mộn não vì những cái vấn đề
người khác đem lại cho mình thì nó cũng
tệ lắm đấy ờ và cái thứ ba đó là sản
phẩm của công ty sản phẩm công ty nó
triền vọng nó phải kiểu tiềm năng rồi
Vân Vân Nói chung là sản phẩm đủ để mình
thích làm với nó nếu mà sản phẩm mà kiểu
bạn cứ đến rồi bạn nhìn sản phẩm Ui kiểu
mình còn thấy là tự mình đang lừa dối
khách hàng tự mình đang bán cái lương
tâm mình đi để làm công việc này Vân Vân
thì cũng phải xem xét lại đúng không ạ
Không cần nhất thiết phải những công
việc kiểu trái đạo đức kiểu bàn lương
tâm mà chỉ những công việc kiểu quá nhàm
chán này hoặc là
kiểu công việc không đem lại cho bạn cái
kiểu động lực hay là cái đam mê hay vân
vân vân đấy cũng được đúng không ạ rất
nhiều cái nên là nên là bạn tìm công
việc mà ít nhất là phải hứng vào hai
trong ba tiêu chí trên Còn không thì
đấy còn không thì sớm muộn và nên là sớm
đúng không ạ Bạn nên kết thúc công việc
anh ngoài đời thì sẽ được lì xì tin
chuẩn không Anh có em Thực ra nếu mà anh
vẫn còn thừ lì xì thì anh sẽ còn sẽ cố
để l sau mấy hôm đấy anh cũng đổi khá
nhiều tiền rồi và mua rất nhiều Bao l
rồi Nên là các bạn gặp tôi trong khoảng
thời gian đấy được thì
các bạn nhắn tin Facebook là tôi đều trả
lời
đừng qua nhà nhắn tin Facebook để anh em
đi cà phê với nhau các thứ thứ thôi qua
nhà ông Định làm gì rồii tôi Tôi sợ mấy
ông qua nhà tôi lắm
chiến thắng đối thủ thì cần phải chiến
thắng bản thân mình
thôi nghe âm Chỉ thứ nhất là bạn phải
hiểu được tôi thường ha nói câu là bạn
phải hiểu chính mình hiểu bình thường là
cái gì à Hiểu địch hiểu ta trăm trận tră
thắng à Thế đ Thực ra chẳng cần phải
hiểu địch đâu chỉ cần hiểu được hiểu
mình hiểu ta tôi toàn nói ngược lại thế
hiểu mình hiểu ta trăm trận Trăng Thắng
ngĩ em Chị bây giờ bản chất làm gì có
địch nào đây Đừng coi ai là kẻ thù cả
đấy Coi chính mình là kẻ thù thôi Thực
ra thực ra là là đấy Theo triết à The
theo đạo gì gì đó thì chính chính mình
mới là kẻ thù lớn nhất của mình đúng
không ạ Thế nên là mình phải hiểu được
Chính Mình đã mình hiểu được bản thân
mình cần gì muốn gì Mình mạnh ở điểm nào
mình yếu ở điểm nào đúng không ạ Mình tự
làm những cái việc quá khả năng mình thì
đúng là mình tự sát thôi đúng không ạ Tự
mình hiểu mình các thứ để
mình ví dụ Giả sử Giả sử nhá bạn không
phải một con người có thể ngồi được 8
tiếng liên tục để làm việc thì bạn
chuyển qua làm thời gian ít hơn 4 tiếng
rồi Ngồi nghỉ 4 tiếng ngồi nghỉ còn
không thì giả sử là cái cái
kiểu à gì nhỉ khả năng tập trung của bạn
kém thì bạn lại còn chia nhỏ ra nữa Thế
kể 30 phút làm xong rồi 5 phút nghỉ 30
phút làm tiếp Vân Vân còn nếu mà bạn mà
còn còn chẳng hiểu được bản thân bạn
kiểu phù hợp hay là kiểu phù hợp với
cách làm hay mọi thứ như nào
thì thì đấy rõ ràng là do bạn bởi vì chỉ
có bạn biết được thôi không ai có thể
định hướng hay khuyên bạn mấy cái điều
đấy Cả đúng không ạ Đấy theo tôi vẫn là
hiểu mình hiểu ta trăm trận trăm thắng
đúng nhỉ hiểu địch hiểu ta mà đúng không
nhớ thế mà đúng không hiểu địch hiểu ta
đúng
người biết ta
nhầ thì bây giờ biến thành biết mình
biết ta này không còn phải biết người
hay biết địch
nữa bởi vì tôi bảo rồi địch địch lớn
nhất chính là mình thôi tự mình giới hạn
bản thân mình đ chứ rất nhiều rất nhiều
thứ
ông nói chung là kiểu Cuộc Sống Ông như
giờ là đa phần vẫn là do ông tự lựa chọn
ông Thế có thể người khác hay là mọi thứ
Nó tác động lên cuộc sống của ông nhưng
mà nó không thể quyết định mọi thứ cho
ông được ông vẫn là người quyết định ví
dụ Giả sử là có một thứ tôi tệ xảy
ra thì ông phải thứ nhất ông coi coi nó
điều có phải điều hiển nhiên xảy ra hay
không Nếu điều hiển nhiên xảy ra thì
thôi đành chấp nhận mình đừng có buồn vì
nó làm gì cả thứ hai đó là ông hãy nghĩ
cách để mà khắc phục đ nó không bao giờ
xảy ra nữa đấy chứ ông cứ xảy ra Ông đổ
tại số phận C thử thử ví dụ điển này
ngay hôm trước thôi tôi lại chuyện lôi
quan điểm cá nhân ra đây kiểu hôm trước
tôi vừa thấy kiểu mấy ông bị bắt vì
không đội mũ hiểm chẳng hạn câu đầu tiên
ông nói là ông ấy do Ông ấy đen đen hôm
đấy Kiểu không đội mũ thì
kiểu kiểu bị bắt các thứ Tôi cảm thấy là
thứ nhất là ông ấy còn không thấy là đấy
là điều có lợi ông ấy khi mà đội mũ thứ
nhất thứ hai là là đừng bao giờ đổ tại
số phận do đen tôi rất hạn chế đổi tại
do số phận đương nhiên là tôi một con
người mê tín thực ra mấy ông sẽ để ý tôi
Thực ra tôi thường hay nói là tôi có
nhiề cái tôi cũng kiê tôi cũng mê tín Có
nhưng mà tôi không mê tín đến nỗi là coi
số phận là mình đã được ă bài được sắp
đặt tôi toàn nghĩ là mình sẽ phải làm
quyết định làm chủ số phận của mình
uôi đang nói giở tự nhiên hệ có Vanga bí
tuổi nhảy sang mảng it Ổn không
anh thế tự cho câu hỏi của các bạn đôi
khi trả lời phần nào
tuổi tác của mình cũng là một cái kiểu
một cái gì đó đúng không ạ
Ờ nhưng mà bây giờ để hỏi sâu hơn Bây
giờ mình chơi l lại chơi cái bài toán là
tôi tôi hỏi rồi tôi tự trả lời nhá đó là
năm câu hỏi vì sao à đấy n Why à f Why À
đấy Kiểu thế tôi sẽ hỏi sâu hơn một tí
nhá Thứ nhất là về cái vế đầu đi Tại sao
với
bạn 30 tuổi lại lại kiểu dạng là một vấn
đề khi mà học it đấy thì bây giờ tôi sẽ
thử Trả lời Hội luôn bạn nhá Thứ nhất là
tầm tuổi này sẽ khó mà kéo minh mẫn hay
là khó mà tiếp thu kiến thức so với so
với kiểu lới tổi trẻ đúng không ạ thứ
hai đó là rất nhiều công ty Bây giờ có
thể không tuyển vì cũng nghĩ đấy Kiểu
bạn khó kiểu thích ứng so với giấy trẻ
đấy thứ ba
à Rồi thứ ba là gì nhỉ thứ ba chính bạn
tự ti vì điều đấy nhưng là chính bạn tự
ti điều đấy thì bạn phải tự thắng bản
thân mình gạt cái đấy đi đã đấy còn hai
cái vế đầu cái việc là nhất là
à Khó thích nghi đ so với giới trẻ đúng
không ạ thì lại phải hỏi ngược lại bạn
Bạn có thích nghi với Mội với kiểu công
việc khác mọi thứ và học lập trình Nếu
mà muốn làm lập trình kiểu bạn muốn mức
lương như nào đã nếu mà Giả sử bạn làm
sang mảng it Nói thẳng luôn là cái Cứ
cho là cái vị tr thấp nhất của it đối
với tôi góp nhìn tôi vẫn coi thấp nhất
nhá Bởi vì nó không yêu cầu rất nhiều
cái ví dụ it support chẳng hạn làm hỗ
trợ các thứ thứ rồi nó thẳng chạy vặt
đấy thì thực ra nó cũng cần nhiều kinh
nghiệm đâu đấy nhưng mà khi mà tôi nghe
bạn hỏi thế này thường là nó có thể liên
quan đến Làm lập trình nó khó khó một tí
hoặc là thậm chí là kiểu dạng là làm
kiểu ba nói chung là kiểu khó khó còn
tester cũng có thể đấy đấy thì bạn cũng
phải xác định rõ ra là bạn phải hỏi một
cái cụ thể hơn là bạn muốn sang cái công
việc nào đã còn nếu mà thậm chí là bạn
còn chưa chọn công việc chưa nghĩ đến
việc chọn công việc đấy Bạn chỉ hỏi
chung chung thế nghĩa là tự bạn cũng làm
khó bản thân rồi vì bạn chưa tìm hiểu kỹ
đúng không ạ Đấy thì còn việc thích nghi
kia để sao cho nó phù hợp thì đấy thì
trước trước đây bạn làm những công việc
khác bạn cảm thấy là bạn phù hợp với
những công việc làm việc kiểu thứ nhất
là với máy tính máy móc hay không Bạn
thích nghi nhanh hay không hay thậm chí
là bạn có chưa động và máy tính bao giờ
đấy th à Tôi đang nói giờ đến đâu nấy
kiểu thế nhưng mà bạn bạn thấy khi mà
tôi hỏi thế bạn cũng sẽ tự mình phải trả
lời những cái câu đấy và tự vỡ lẽ thôi
đúng không ạ hỏi thế Thực ra những cái
câu Tôi vừa hỏi Thực ra là khá khó để mà
trả lời luôn Tôi nghĩ là bạn bây giờ
đang cảm nhận thấy thế nhưng mà chính vì
khó trả lời nên là Thành ra bạn mấy đang
bối rối nhưng mà bấy giờ tôi đã tách nhỏ
cái câu hỏi bạn ra rồi khi bạn trả lời
được dần dần Nói chung là bạn cứ tách
nhỏ câu hỏi tách nhỏ câu hỏi ra như thế
nó thể ra được nhiều câu hỏi hơn có
nhưng mà bạn trả lời những câu hỏi bé bé
bé dễ đấy đã nó sẽ trả lời được câu hỏi
lớn ch bạn đúng không ạ Giống như một
cái đề bài khó đấy bạn phải chia học
toán rồi mà đúng không ạ Bạn phải chia
các thứ thứ ra dần dần bạn mới giải chứ
bạn ngay từ đầu bạn giải một bài toán
rất là dài thì bạn sẽ
không không thể hiểu được không thể nghĩ
được hết thế đúng không ạ Bạn cứ chia
nhỏ ra rồi bạn làm dần dần thì bạn sẽ
làm được thôi Ui tôi vừa tư vấn một cái
đỉnh vãi đúng là nói chuyện với kiểu nhà
tiên chi hay các thứ mình phải có một
cái cách nói chuyện kiểu
khác Anh nghĩ sao về về
năm học thành công
cốc hôm trước hôm trước có người nói Hỏi
hẳn trên nhóm rồi là em từng đi nghĩa vụ
và có nên viết nó trong CV hay không Tôi
cũng từng chia sẻ hôm trước một lần nữa
rồi thực ra là khó chắc chắn tôi sẽ
không thể nói là các bạn kiểu không nên
nghĩa vụ cái này còn đang Lào chị nữa
nhưng mà
À tôi sẽ nói ưu và nhược của nó à ưu thì
ưu Thực ra các bạn biết rồi Nhược à
không chính xác Nhược các bạn biết rõ
nhất còn ưu nó
là các bạn cứ nghĩ là yêu chỉ đơn giản
là ờ thì mình có thêm rèn luyện quân đội
các thứ các thứ
ờ đúng không
ạ kiểu nó sẽ có thêm kỷ luật các thứ thứ
nhưng các bạn không hề biết sau đó nữa
đúng không ạ trong khi mà cái thực sự là
kỷ luật là một cái thứ rất là quan trọng
thứ hai đó là
à nế nếu nếu có thể các bạn vẫn nên đi
sớm giống như kiểu học xong đi luôn Nó
vẫn rất tốt còn hơn là sau này bạn kiểu
bây giờ giả sử cứ dùng từ là bạn Né đi
né được đi Giả sử thế bạn à mà về sau về
sau bạn vẫn đương nhiên là kiểu gì về
sau nếu mà thiếu thì bạn vẫn phải đi
thôi nếu bạn sức khỏe mọi thứ đều ổn thì
lúc đấy khi bạn đang đi làm nửa chừng
thì
bạn kiểu nghỉ đi nghĩa vụ về mọi thứ
khác biệt hẳn ấy thì lúc đấy Bạn bị
choáng rất nhiều 4 năm học của bạn tính
ra nó vẫn chỉ là lý thuyết thôi và cái
lý thuyết đấy bạn vẫn thể ôn lại được
còn về cái thực hành khi mà bạn đi làm
một thời gian rồi ấ Nói thẳng luôn bạn
sẽ không bao giờ muốn Kiểu nghỉ đi làm
để mà đi nghĩ vụ nói thẳng là như thế Ờ
nên thà học xong rồi đi luôn người ta
vẫn luôn khuyên là như thế học xong đi
luôn và khi mà bạn viết là mà bạn đã
từng đi nghĩa vụ trong CV tính ra cái
cái CV bạn nó vẫn được trọng dụng hơn
rất nhiều so với người khác vì bạn thể
hiện bạn là người có trách nhiệm về xã
hội vân vân và có kỷ luật các thứ thứ nó
được đánh giá rất là cao và đặc biệt
nhiều nhiều Nói chung là ná ná ná ná
giống như là kiểu nhiều người tôi cũng
từng nói đó là bằng cấp Đại học Thực ra
nó không quan trọng như thế nhưng nó vẫn
là một cái ý nghĩa rất tốt nếu mà th sự
bạn có bạn vẫn nên ghi vào để mà người
khác thấy là bạn đã từng bỏ ngần đấy
thời gian ra để bạn phấn đấu để bạn ở
một nơi ổn định để bạn kiểu làm được một
cái gì đó hoàn thành nó thể hiện trách
nhiệm của bạn Vân Vân không phải con
người kiểu là không thể qua được một cái
gì đó bài bản không qua rèn luyện không
qua huấn luyện không qua cái gì đó rèn
dũa nên là thành ra là họ nghĩ là họ sẽ
phải đào tạo bạn khá khó nếu mà bạn chưa
qua một cái gì đó các bạn hiểu không ạ
Đấy Nói chung là nếu mà bạn có những cái
đấy Bạn nên ghi vào rất
tốt anh thích dự án nặng về code hay về
phân tích hơn ờ câu này một câu rất là
hay Tôi chưa gi nghĩ đến Ừ Hiện tại hiện
tại nhá thì code ở công ty tôi không hề
nặng nói thằng luôn là là bài toán
nghiệp vụ rất là là đơn giản ngá thẳng
luôn b vì trang trang thê mại điện tử
tính là quanh đi quần lại nó chỉ là bán
hàng rồi Mọi thứ rồi các tính năng hỗ
trợ việc đấy nhưng mà công ty tôi đang
có lợi thế đó là vì dữ liệu mọi thứ hay
là dữ liệu khách hàng rất là lớn tập
khách hàng lớn rồi Vân Vân Mình cũng
muốn làm tối ưu trải nghiệm để mà cạnh
tranh với các nền tảng khác nên thành ra
mình lại đi sâu về bài toán phân tích
chứ code nghiệp vụ mặt nghiệp vụ nó
không hề Khó Nói thảng luôn không hề khó
đấy Nên là nên là tôi đang khá thích
công việc hiện tại chứ nếu mà code khó
thì kiểu là làm thuật toán nhiều kiểu
làm ma trận hay các thứ thứ làm thậm chỉ
ai hay là blockchain thì đúng là nó khó
ấy thì chắc là có khi là tôi không
hợp em thấy vấn đề nặng nhất là tuổi tác
vì Việt Nam đang số trên 30 rất hiếm
công ty tuyển đấy Thực ra thì
cái việc bạn ứng tuyển vào nó lại qua
lại cái câu câu chuyện là vừa nãy tôi
nói về việc hợp hay không hợp nếu mà Giả
sử bạn vào một công ty nói đúng là đa số
như bạn bảo
thì thì có nhiều nơi là có HR nó không
thực sự tốt Tôi cảm thấy thế thế nào tốt
tốt ở đây làm chẻ họ cứ kiểu lướt lướt
qua civ các bạn chứ không hề gì thực sự
năng lực hay để ý con người các bạn nó
sẽ
kiểu ví dụ rõ ràng là ví dụ một điển
hình hồi trước tôi cũng bị dính tôi có
chia sẻ rồi đó là khi mà tôi ghi cái
phần kinh nghiệm của tôi rất là nhiều ấy
tôi không ghi bằng cấp của tôi ấ người
ta vẫn inbox hỏi tôi là có bằng cấp gì
không để họ còn tạm xét duyệt ý tôi cảm
thấy nó bị buồn cười vì rõ ràng là cái
trình độ kinh nghiệm của mình toàn cao
thừa luôn so với cái bên họ ứng tuyển
chứ đừng nói việc họ phải yêu cầu bằng
cấp đấy nh đấy là một ví dụ điển hình
chị ạ HR mà không đúng chên môn ấy thực
ra họ sẽ chỉ làm mọi thứ theo kiểu là
dập khuôn kiểu như thế thì họ có thể sẽ
không tuyển Mình thậm chị nhưng mà một
khi mà công ty mà kiểu đánh giá thì kiểu
Ừ bạn này tuy là như này nhưng mà bạn ấy
thể hiện được con người bạn ấy bạn ấy
cũng vẫn gọi là tự tin để ứng tuyển thì
nhiều công ty sẽ thích bởi rất nhiều
công ty là tuyển con người bạn chứ không
phải tuyển năng lực của bạn à không phải
không phải năng lực mà dùng từ như
này tuyển trình độ hay cái gì đại khái
là bạn có thể chưa có nhiều kinh nghiệm
thì họ vẫn s tuyển Miễn là mình thể hiện
được cái con người mình ra thôi con
người mình là một
người kiểu dạng là biết phấn đấu các thứ
nhanh nhẹn biết tiếp thu và làm việc ổn
mọi thứ th Hàn tàn đường mà có sao
rồi hôm nay buổi tâm sự khá là dài tôi
kh nọng dần rồi Ờ m không cò thắc mắc gì
không
thì chắc là buổi h ma cứ tạm kết thúc
đây đã Ờ hẹn mấy ông chắc là sang năm
mới tí chắc là tôi sẽ đăng bài thông báo
đó là chắc là chúng ta sẽ nghỉ đến tận
ngày 21 để mà mình sẽ lại livestream
tiếp Chào mấy ông